[Laughter]
hey you guys jenny's already yelling at
me i didn't yell at you i just i just
said turn
turn that volume down that's not what i
sound like that's not what i sound like
i just said turn that volume down okay
well because i have to tell you every
time
well because it's distracting okay it's
like because i hear a noise and then
like two two or three seconds later i
hear it from over there and i'm just
kind of like i'm getting an echo i'm
already feeling fat today and you start
[ __ ] with me i'm not [ __ ] with you
that's all i told you is turn the volume
down all right he always like i say
something to him and then he repeats it
back like i said it like turn that
volume yeah and i did not absolutely did
not say it like that i just said it in a
normal [ __ ] voice
but thank you for trying to make me look
like an [ __ ] that's that's really
awesome
i did it i just told you to show the
[ __ ] value so who's who's in the
comments
all the usual folks yeah you said we
were going to have company yeah we
thought we were yeah they never got back
with me they were saying yeah yeah we
you know [ __ ] tony was like yeah i
want to go out to escalator escalada and
i said dude man you live with her you
ask her
it's his wife you know what i mean and
he goes okay i'll ask her in a minute
and then he never got back with me
and i says all right well you tell send
me a message in the morning because i
got to go to sleep it was and i guess
they slept through it man it's [ __ ]
hot in here can i turn the air
conditioner off well you can this is why
right here well i don't like i said i
don't turn the fan on in here in the in
the day the light's on too so you did
that well because i was painting my
nails
i was painting my nails earlier so i had
to put the lights on because i couldn't
see
it's dark in here which usually is good
but when i have to do
really really close-up work like that
like painting my [ __ ] fingernails i
can't i'm getting so [ __ ] blind i
hate it so much so grandpa's in here
maniacs in here tammy's in here no need
for me he's in here
cheryl's in here
i wonder if tina's going to show up i
don't know i haven't seen him in such a
long time yeah oh i just kicked you
german's got sandra
the german the germans got her yeah so
dj minak said she said we're gonna have
a company i put on pants for nothing
[Laughter]
i'm sorry yeah what you usually watch us
like
naked from the waist down like donald
duck we can't see you man
or can we
[Laughter]
uh uh amanda gear says when you guys
fuss it's funny as hell
[Music]
oh it's new what you got it hooked up
back there
yeah it wasn't like that before well i
stole that table from the other room
because there was nothing on it
because there was so much [ __ ] on the
floor okay i you know what yesterday i
worked in the morning and then i said
you know what i'm gonna clean this [ __ ]
okay so i kind of straightened stuff up
mostly it was the bathroom the bathroom
wasn't filthy i mean i usually keep it
clean
my house is clean i showed you guys but
yeah but i mean we tied it up a little
bit yeah but i was like well vacuumed in
here in a couple weeks the bathroom
needed like a deep clean like scrubbing
the tub and all that kind of stuff which
i only do like once every
few months or so but you know what i
mean
well i'll do like a little [ __ ] kind
of like wipe down and stuff but it's
like i don't get in there with like the
scrubby brush like yeah unless it gets
really but honestly one thing that's
nice about this house as opposed to our
old house
our old house
we had super hard water okay because
yeah you would like you would clean i
would clean the shower then like a week
or two later the bottom of the shower
was like orange yeah and it was a
plexiglass shower it's like you could
fit five people in there we tried
we had to grease them up a little bit
yeah yeah and it like it it was big old
it had like a plexiglass door and the
seals were starting to give out in it
and keep that and it was clear you know
and to keep that [ __ ] looking [ __ ]
spotless was a pain in the ass that hard
water
god it's like i felt like every time i
cleaned that bathroom i had to get in
there with my [ __ ] because i have a
little it's not a toothbrush but it's a
little scrub brush that kind of looks
like a toothbrush that came with my
cleaning kit and i'm just and i had to
get down there with the grout
and the uh to get all the orange out and
you had to bleach it and bleach it
when the landlord moved in there and
took over he tore that thing out
oh really did you really
tore that out well it wasn't in that
greatest shape to be honest with you and
honestly there was like a there was a
crack on the outside the the cement on
the outside and you know and it leaked a
little bit it didn't leak into the
outside of the bathroom it was just they
put a new shower stall in there new kind
of shower a new bathtub everything it
changed all that
and then a whole house tile that
expensive tile like we have down
downstairs
see now i kind of wish we could we could
do that to this house eventually because
[ __ ] car
the carpet's only upstairs pretty much
yeah there's no carpet downstairs which
is fine except no with the other
the other bedroom down there has
has carpet
but yeah it's still not that much of it
but it's not that much yeah but it's
like it's new
yeah carpets in here pretty new they are
and uh you know which if you're gonna do
this you couldn't do it entirely dude
wood
because it's a wood floor
i just kind of wish like more houses
i mean i guess you see it more with uh
houses that have been built like really
recently
they're going more toward like the no
carpet route where like the whole house
is just tile or wood floor and that's
like so much better it's so much cleaner
well the reason why they did carpet
before is it cheaper well yeah i know
well that's only that's the reason they
still do it now
yeah but this i mean there's really no
reason to have carpet in florida it's
not like the floors get cold or anything
like that and it's like it's a cheap
floor cover yeah
and it's
you know what you know what's funny i
don't know why i just thought it was
just
linoleum that she was even cheaper
remember that [ __ ] it'll be all wavy
yeah it was in my grandma's house it was
terrible
um
i used to live in an apartment in
daytona
and
it had
carpet in the bathroom
who does that who puts carpet
in the bathroom
i mean how you can't ever keep that [ __ ]
clean it just smells like a wet dog all
the time yeah you'd have to have carpet
shampoo that's what i mean it's like so
like we
you know i move into the apartment and
i'm just kind of like
seriously what the [ __ ] who like what
the decided to put this in here i think
some people have done that without
really even thinking about it without
even realizing the ramifications i saw
one the other day i saw this video the
other day that was um
it was like what was it called it was
like architectural like what the [ __ ]
or something like that and it was just
like all these pictures that people have
posted of houses they were you know
gonna renovate or something like that
and there was just like weird [ __ ] in
here like here's like half a toilet like
on when there's like a wall in between
but there was one bathroom that not only
had carpet on the floor it also had
carpet on the walls
yeah can you imagine what that place
like smelled like after a little while
holy [ __ ] they're asking for going out
tonight
uh
i don't know
i could go or not go it does i don't
really care the thing about it though is
that because barbarella is moving at the
end of february yeah they're doing
essentially two memento mori's
they're doing one on friday the 18th
okay so next friday next friday um and
they're doing one on the following
monday right
i mean the barbarella that on friday
night is not exactly the same because
it's three djs instead of just dimitri
um
but it's gonna be a similar thing like
industrial type stuff yeah so
that's gonna be like a friday night and
then the monday night
so i don't know if you wanted to like
save
money and wait until because like next
friday for sure we should probably go
out but we got to go downtown we got to
go to downtown orlando all right we'll
just save it up till next week then you
know
i mean if you wanted to go i didn't know
what was going on and i haven't been to
mannequins in a while but you know
well if you honestly why don't we go
tomorrow if you want to go why don't we
go tomorrow
all right is it not as good on saturday
night it's good on saturday well that's
true
but it's okay it's all right
it's all right we can if you want to
because
we just have to say saving that money
makes a better idea if we got
those two nights
that's that's quite a bit of money we'll
just uh because you know we'll [ __ ]
spend
so
we might we might just want to hold off
and do those two weeks yeah i mean it's
up to you if you really had your hearts
out on youtube i'll hold off till next
time then we can but i was just telling
you
because i knew that once in a couple
weeks anyway
well this is a short month it's february
wow what
and monday's valentine's day she wants
to wrestle you trying to get me to
wrestle huh
amanda gear says i love downtown orlando
it's really sad that barbarella is
leaving but i can understand why they
are yeah
i was changing down there well orlando
weekly did like a really big article
about it and um they talked they talked
to uh john john gardner the guy
i saw his explanation i didn't believe
it no but i'm just saying that you know
they've been there a long time he's like
it's not the landlord i've had the same
landlord all the time that club's been
there for like 37 years it just doesn't
get the movement that it used to because
the [ __ ] crime there's been a spike
in crime down there and people aren't
going out covet is a problem is part of
the problem
but also you know people getting shot
and he did make a good point too which
is kind of related to that is that the
clientele of barbarella tends to be
slightly older yeah and they weren't
replacing yeah so part of it though was
the fact that he wasn't [ __ ] he
wasn't
well here's the thing
in orlando you can't go for a younger
crowd because there isn't a younger
crowd
for some of the type of music type
events he would put in there like let's
say for instance he says well i want to
go a little bit younger i want to get
the people in the early 20s the only
thing that would be would be like maybe
that would fit for that place to be like
cold wave and [ __ ] like that
and that's not gonna pull enough people
they have those nights well they tried
to do that and they didn't really get
that many people like some people came
but not that yeah
and what's packing it in down there's
the [ __ ] um
is the rap crowd now and they shoot the
place up
what they tried to do well actually the
most successful night at barbarella
for a long time i don't think they do it
anymore was uh mac and cheese which was
wednesday nights and that was just like
cheesy ass music 80s and 90s like they
played like vanilla ice and you know
like cheesy 80s [ __ ] like nothing cool
like new wave or anything but just like
the lamest [ __ ] imaginable and it was
funny because like young people were
going to that yeah and they got a
younger crowd for that yeah for a while
they did friday nights that was like
indy yeah and that was real popular too
i went there a couple nights on friday
and it was just it was so packed you
couldn't even like hardly move in there
younger crowd just wasn't going out as
much as the older crowd and then when
cove had hit it was even worse yeah
because a lot of people just said [ __ ]
it they're like [ __ ] and they don't have
any money yeah a lot of it is they don't
have any money
um
the dudes don't have any money the
[ __ ] the girls don't have any money
they don't have any money
but i'm not sure i don't blame them i
mean you know they're lit they're
growing up in a bad time
you know bad time
that's in the past two years
so a lot of people that you know
got to club age for the past couple
years never showed up
yeah that's true
let's see two years worth of [ __ ]
harvest was missed when it came to
harvest of harvest yeah that's the
people i mean like i said
yeah i mean you do have and the weird
thing about particularly the barbarella
and mannequins type crowd that we hang
around with is a lot of them
you know uh have kids that are old
enough to go to clubs and a lot of times
they'll bring their kids yeah you know
what i mean which i think is funny so
there's like two generations i can't
really think of too many other nightclub
scenes that would do that kind of stuff
yeah and you can't wear a part where
people where people bring they're just
like hey here's why he just turned 21 so
here he is
yeah
he's like he's been waiting for years
and years he's like he's always jealous
that we could go out and he could yeah
that's very rare though
his parents aren't like that no i don't
think these are the kids but we do know
like we do know several uh several
people that have kids
these are the kids of scenesters
yeah
and they get cool it's just it's funny
because i kind of feel like i know i
know one couple that had kids and like
when when they're one teenage she
actually kind of went against it for a
little while she's like what the [ __ ]
and try to do her own thing but now that
she's older she's like okay she got back
into goth now so yeah she wanted to
rebel against her parents for a little
while princess but when she got older
she was she gave her her first pair of
shoes
when she was really little well she was
what 12 13 12 or 13. and that was a long
time ago yeah now she's old enough to
like well two years later she was old
enough to wear those there was [ __ ]
when we were in high school 15 year old
girls would wear that 15 seconds no i
was talking about going to a club oh
yeah
you know you could wear the boots
whenever yeah
uh let's see uh zach says i'm not much
of a booze guy
for me it's always either too sweet or
too bitter what are some good middle
ground type drinks gin and tonic
that's pretty
tart though
who's this zach zach
zach why are you asking these kind of
questions zach
why is he not allowed to ask us no
gamers just know everything about
alcohol we talk about
i don't think that's true oh yeah they
know everything about style and alcohol
and what drinks fruit and [ __ ] you
know come on man
get your c3po status on know all that
[ __ ]
that's good i'm not your bartender no
but okay look
it's either too sweet or too wet now too
strong too
bitter a gin and tonic that's about
middle of the road at least it is
although like i said it's it's kind of
tart and like kind of acidic
a um
a screwdriver's middle of the road for
me
maybe the orange juice is what's making
it too sweet
i don't find orange juice sweetness you
just hold it you just use less orange
juice yeah or you can actually get uh
lower sugar orange juices i'm pretty
sure i don't worry about no i'm just
saying that if you're really i just use
less orange juice
vodka tonic yeah
i don't love vodka tonics they don't
taste like a lot to me but yeah they're
good um they're good too if you're if
you still want a drink but want
something that's not super calorie rich
because i think vodka tonic is like the
least
uh you know high calorie of all of the
drinks go drink black velvet which is a
50 50 mix
of guinness stout
and um
oh hard apple cider or hard cider 50 50
mix it's good
dj maniac says uh consider this country
music back in the 40s and 50s was prima
primarily about drinking fighting and
[ __ ] it was the gangster wrap of its
day yeah that's true
[Laughter]
that's true
um
bloody mary's actually i i actually
quite like a bloody mary i don't have
them that often
but every now and then i don't ever get
them at clubs though because they don't
i don't even remember i think i got a
bloody mary at uh the grotto one time
but i don't think uh barbarella or
anywhere like that i don't think they
have zing zang or they have bloody mary
mix or anything so i don't think i've
ever got one out other than that i
usually have those at home because every
now and then if
i'm at the grocery store and they have a
good deal on zing zang i'll get that
but those are
i don't know that's almost kind of like
a
meal a bloody berry
okay so uh
today is uh friday it's open lines
friday
if you guys have any questions if you
want to talk about any cases you want to
talk about paranormal unsolved uh
mysteries um
true crime anything yeah current events
just you can just go ahead and drop a
question in the uh comment section of me
and jenny will get on it
um
other than that zach did say that he had
a
screwdriver at a nudist beach is the
only time he didn't hate vodka he said
he said it was good so
yeah yeah screwdriver is usually my
go-to i like vodka mixed with orange
juice or i like vodka mixed with
um
i'm also a big fan of cherry flavored
vodka mixed with sprite that's awesome
graham's just talking about shampoo man
that's fred g sanford's [ __ ] drink
king of trash
of his junk empire
did you know that that was based on a
british tv show
nope steptoe and son
they were they were uh grizzle little
white guys okay
it's funny though because i saw it when
i was over there i mean it was old yeah
by the time i was over there but you
know there were still like reruns on
every now and then but i thought it was
like really funny that they had based
that whole [ __ ] and i don't think
most people know that if you like bloody
mary's make a bloody mary with something
called uh zing zang yeah i just talked
about that like a little bit yet
yeah i really i really like bloody
mary's yeah you can get that at a
grocery store
yeah i think it's usually what like six
to eight dollars for like a pretty big
mixer yeah the mixer it's real heavy in
celery seeds it's good that's good
though i like that real real um
tangy
real good it's funny every time you
don't eat any seasoning every time i
have a bloody mary i always think to
myself you know what would be really
good right now just like uh a skewer
with a big piece of rare steak in it
like stuck in the bloody pan we have
zing zang in the back refrigerator
did we help what's that been in there oh
a year at least a couple years oh my god
i gotta go check it you didn't tell me
that yeah
that's been in there the whole time and
i didn't know yeah i thought we ran out
because i didn't even i don't even
remember that bottle of it i don't even
remember the last time by now i gotta go
check it yeah because i [ __ ] man that
must have been it's been over years ago
i mean that's got to be more than it's
gonna go yeah it's probably throw that
out i don't even remember when we bought
that long time ago it's got so many
spices in it maybe it doesn't go bad i
mean i'm sure it probably does get bad
yeah yeah i don't know
that's kind of like how long does it
think
sauce let's google it how long does
worcestershire sauce last there's so
many spices in there it might be okay
i'm not gonna i don't know i'm not gonna
risk if it smells okay i would totally
drink it though i'm not proud nah throw
it out just get some more we got it at
the grocery store yeah
yeah they gotta have carrots they got it
at publix public schools that's where i
bought it before yeah
i didn't even know that was still back
there yeah it just shows what i know i
don't ever go in the garage refrigerator
i don't know what's in there
it's like it's a mystery box
because that was like a bunch of [ __ ]
that we took from our old house and i
don't even know because we had the
refrigerator in the garage in our old
house and i didn't even know with half
of what was back in there most of the
time either
hey uh jen you guys ever heard of the
junko
furuta case never heard of faruta have
you wait a minute do do do do
uh
i don't think so that it sounds slightly
familiar but
i can't really like place it at the
moment
okay um
mark says hi guys i'm interested to know
what tom thought was going on in the
haunted house in boston he stayed at
thanks oh that's a good time yeah that's
it that's a good thing because i don't
know i'm sure you've mentioned it before
but i don't think that you like went
into it in any depth sorry that's pookie
messing with her a little she has a
little uh thing that has treats in it
that she knocks over
and the trees come out of its butt
what's weird i don't know if you guys
ever listened to um
redonkulous it's another channel
terrace pops
that's his channel and he's a ex special
forces us army ranger airborne guy was
in for like 30 years
and um
he was triple tabbed man he had ranger
sf and [ __ ] uh what was the other tab
that he had
anyway um get it pokey
they put him in charge of abu ghraib
prison after that
oh [ __ ] scandal went down
he was in charge of that him and his
unit
and uh
he said that place [ __ ] gave him the
creeps
he saw what he believed were ghosts
there shadows and just [ __ ] bad
feelings and stuff
because they knew the details of what
had happened in
and out at abu ghraib
prison
and it's weird he had a lot
of similar experiences to what i've had
dreaming true having feelings having
visions
dreaming about people and talking about
talking to them in your dreams and then
you found out that they remembered the
conversation they had it in a dream too
that kind of stuff
um
ghosts
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
he it's happened to him
it's funny you know
in military and peop people have this
weird
ideas about uh guys that are have
military and police type backgrounds
that uh
that you know
super straight laced and real uh
[ __ ] cut and dry nah man [ __ ]
every dude that i knew that is in that
profession had weird things happen to
them because
when you're kind of at the outer edge or
the extreme edges of
of emotion
and stress
consciousness kind of becomes a little
warped you start having [ __ ] weird
parent what people would call like
paranormal experiences out-of-body
experiences near-death experiences
so whatever it is that causes these
things it's it's in the animal world and
it has something to do with the extremes
of physics and probably something with
quantum physics and and consciousness
um
closest i've been able to get to it
would be the stuart hammerhoff's work
and he's a an anesthesiologist that was
doing experiments on people with that
anesthesia and how consciousness works
and what is it you know i mean it's not
computation like digital computation in
a computer that's part of it
but there's an analog component it might
have something to do with quantum
particles
and once it goes quantum man it's not
normal physics you know
and
he
hammer off says you know that kind of
explains some of this paranormal stuff
it makes it where it might be plausible
and i know it's plausible i [ __ ] seen
weird [ __ ] and other guys have seen
where she got grabbed hers in the
comments section he long time in law
enforcement
and he'll probably tell you too i don't
know he hasn't talked to me about it but
guys get weird feelings that come true
when you're in that business or
premonitions and uh
and that's where all this [ __ ] came from
these ancient religions you know like
the chinese with chi you know and ying
force and yang force which which was
that's what
lucas and and and his
george lucas and his teacher
[ __ ]
richard campbell
richard campbell was his name right
joseph joseph campbell that's right
richard campbell was my friend who
killed himself
uh joseph campbell um
[ __ ]
they
they made up star wars in the force
based upon chinese type philosophies
and life energy chi
there's definitely something to it
definitely you know
um
but anyway
one of the things that i ran into was
this [ __ ] house it was just a bad
house when i got out of the army moved
in there with an army but in mind named
eric
and i could tell he was getting weirded
out in that house and he would deny us
this man's [ __ ] something in his
house no man yeah it's just it's just a
creepy old house
we'd have girls over and they didn't
want to [ __ ] walk down the hallways
by themselves he had to wait outside the
damn bathroom door for them to take a
pee and then they go back to the bedroom
whether you someone would spend the
night there they didn't like it
and um i had weird things happen to me
man felt like this thing was over my
[ __ ] shoulder watching me and that
was that was the culmination of it
having weird dreams about puppies
starving to death inside the pipes way
down underneath the bottom of the house
and inside the walls um
i found a damn secret
compartment in the upper
attic that went down and there was a box
in the end of it and [ __ ] i walked
all the way down there to go get that
box walking across the rung so that
[ __ ] ceiling
because there was no floor
and i brought it back it didn't weigh
anything you know and eric had that damn
flashlight on me we were spooked and
then he's like man how much i bet that's
a baby in there
i would have said a severed head but
yeah and
opened it up it was empty it just had a
[ __ ] um in the bottom of it was a
single sheet of newspaper
like a liner on the bottom of it and the
date was like back in the 60s 50s or so
see like [ __ ] like that
that's not really all that overt yeah
that creeps me out more than like more
overt [ __ ] because why is that there
like who left that there what were the
circumstances like the mystery of it is
very intriguing to me what ended up
happening eventually is um
in this house was old victorian house
1800s
the layout of the rooms didn't make any
sense you know because victorian houses
didn't have centralized hallways you
know i mean you walk from one room and
to the other and you had to go through
people's bedrooms to get to the damn
bathroom that kind of weird it's like
hey don't mind me i'm just going to the
can yeah it didn't
didn't make any sense you know
but uh
ouch
um
it ended up [ __ ] in the end it felt
like i was getting got came under
psychic attack by something that was
just [ __ ] invisible it was like right
over my shoulder
uh just like this huge [ __ ] panic
attack
and at that time i had a
i always had a lot of guns you know
i had a jeep a ruger gp 100
stainless steel 37 magnum revolver and i
pulled that [ __ ] out and [ __ ] just
felt like i had a point of something but
i couldn't [ __ ] point it at nothing i
felt like i was just being attacked by
something
and i just said get the [ __ ] off me on
my burning hat i'm gonna burn the damn
house down i'll burn this [ __ ] house
down it's your house
it's your house i'm gonna burn it the
[ __ ] down and it vanished
vanished never [ __ ] with me again
because i realized that the only thing i
could do was threaten the house
hmm it worked
yeah i guess so it was trying to defend
the house
interesting yeah trying to get me out of
the house i [ __ ] said i was gonna
burn the house down
it kind of reminds me of a book i read
recently where like the house was not
so much haunted as the house was like a
living organism in the sense that
it could kind of
produce
people and it kind of had
it was like alive the house was like
alive like it at the end like it gets up
and like walks around you know what i
mean well we ended
we ended up getting different
girlfriends and splitting up
um
and
then like a couple years later i [ __ ]
mentioned that how we were still in
boston being here
and um i was with stephanie
at that time and i saw eric and i said
dude you remember that old house because
do that [ __ ] house i'd be terrified
and i said you felt that in that house
didn't he because yeah man there was
something in that house
something [ __ ] watching us
and that was just the only way we could
describe it
weird
that was the closest thing to a ghost
i've ever seen now i've seen poltergeist
which is not a ghost i thought it was a
ghost but recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis
i've also had out-of-body experiences in
the form of near-death experience and
i've had um
uh what do you call it
spontaneous obe or spontaneous astral
projection
in front of a witness when i was in the
army that was weird
he saw it
but he wouldn't tell me much of what he
saw i could find him too i know where he
won't talk to me he's scared of me
yeah
um everybody was bringing up the junco
ferruto faruda case um i haven't like
once you gave me the details i did kind
of remember reading about that uh so i
wrote it down i will put it in the poll
at some point because we should do a
show about it uh zach says the family
murders case from australia horrified me
for a few years i'm 99 sure we did do a
show on that i think it was a long time
ago but we did
uh gramphther says terence is an
interesting guy but needs a good woman
in his life
[Laughter]
terence has a lot of paranormal stories
our paranormal army army stories about
knowing when a sniper was getting ready
to strike known when a
um an artillery strike was inbound and
yeah
the army knows about that
we had a psychic unit um it was called
project stargate this is way back in the
80s
and they were doing remote viewing but
most of it's still classified they won't
tell you anything about it
and uh they
that project vanished
it became something else but they're
now i know the [ __ ] military does
dumb [ __ ] they'll believe dumb [ __ ]
all right um
there's been a couple of
confirmed occasions where
a magician fooled generals
with sleight of hand tricks and the
general absolutely believed that it was
some kind of psychic phenomena but it
wasn't
but
there were parts of the government
especially back in the 60s and the
intelligence agencies that totally
believed in psychic abilities and the
russians definitely did
and were you trying to use it to snoop
on people
was it desperation or maybe they
had had observed it i mean i saw
poltergeist and other stuff and
you know recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis [ __ ] mind-blowing
and uh so i imagine that they know about
it
and it could be
that
when you go back to the old chinese lore
it's kind of where lucas and
ripped off the idea of the jedi
dudes with lightsabers and psychic
abilities right well that came from the
chinese concept
of swordsmen that had unbelievable
abilities that were basically verged on
psychic
well that's the same as soldiers having
[ __ ] a good psychic affinity
and
because those guys are living more in
the animal world so it's more about
emotion
and i think that's the key so
animals can do weird things that it's
difficult to explain you know good good
homing abilities
good senses that things are good about
that are going to happen that's part of
their defenses
is it extra sensory though
maybe not maybe it's just that some of
our sensory apparatus is not physical
maybe some of it's quantum like a field
of quantum particles around you
that can somehow sense things or
electromagnetic sensing electromagnetic
stuff
and you're getting images in your mind
of what's possible because you know the
mind is a pretty good
computer i guess if you want like an
analog computer the imagination
but either way it doesn't matter it
works whenever you start questioning try
to force it
as i read some declassified stuff on it
that came out a project
the stargate
they said the problem with psychic
abilities is that they were not reliable
on a battlefield if you put a guy under
a lot of stress he couldn't do it he had
to be in a relaxed state he had to be
very detached from it and then what you
the information you got from him might
have been accurate but not enough to
change the course of a battle so they
didn't most people didn't think it was
worth anything
i could see that that it was more about
that than a satellite was a lot of
satellite photographs was a lot better
and spies that shit's a lot better
because you know exact things like times
dates locations
the psychic stuff is just more like just
imagery vague
yeah i mean even if it is real yeah it's
not really all that useful in those
applications right like a guy says he
can see it
he can see what's gonna happen but he's
not sure the time or the exact location
just it's in between a couple buildings
in a car and this and that well [ __ ]
there's a lot of places where that could
be sure you know
uh zach is asking if you remember the
address of the place in boston
because he wants to look it up yeah i
had it for a while but i don't remember
it offhand
um
i found it on google earth because i
knew where to look at it knew knew where
to look for it
it was in arlington
massachusetts around side of medford
near medford it was things called
medford but i members in arlington
and it was off of trying to remember the
name of that street
um i could i can find it i remember the
bus route how to get there behind a
it's in a little court
there's a laundromat here and a little
liquor store right there there's a
little
driveway that goes in there looks like a
back alley but it opens up into a court
with like five houses from the 1800s
that are right there
uh but i can't tell you the
the address off the top of my head i
mean i should have lived there forever i
think it was
311 something or other
cedar cedar street
cedar street i think is what it was
or no
would have been court it might have been
cedar court
hmm
should look at a long time yeah you
should look it up again i remember you
looking outside right
on google earth one time yeah it's still
there last i checked
grant there's hammer said uh i have a
revenant in my house bb's occasionally
dropped from the ceiling the tv will
turn the channel on its own the gas
fireplace will spontaneously ignite yeah
we had some [ __ ] like that happening tv
turned on
all the time the tv turned itself on all
the time
all the time it also happened in our
bedroom a couple times but usually it
was the living room tv lose your living
room i mean you sometimes it was the
bedroom tv but almost always it was
because i would usually get up and go
and make coffee and then the living room
tv would be on
and no and hardly anybody like we never
watched that tv no that tv was like more
decorations yeah it was just kind of
there i mean we always watch tv in the
bedroom so nobody really watched the
living room tv but
almost every morning it was on by itself
that was weird and we did ask like when
the cable guy came once we said is there
anything that would like explain like
why that's happening and a doorbell
would ring in the middle of the night
yeah that happened a few times
the garage door
opened a few times
um
that was pretty creepy
you said you saw that one door open up
going out to the garage i didn't see
that
yeah well it was the same night that the
garage door like went up and then you
went out there to see like what the [ __ ]
was going on and the door from the
laundry room into the garage opened
on its own like slowly like inward like
that
and if you remember that door at the old
house it doesn't do that like you
actually if you were carrying stuff out
to the garage you had to prop that door
open because it just would close
it's displaced frustration it's whatever
i'm frustrated you can't do any things
in it so it's kind of like it displaces
it and it does it
it's fast
it's weird pulled down some parts of the
shelf and threw the damn statues on the
ground of the little horses
yeah when it pulled the damn railing off
the top of that when that was when it
pulled the trim off the top of that
cupboard it went boom and one side that
[ __ ] shot up
i couldn't believe that i saw it whoa
whoa whoa
jumped out of my skin and it happened
when my
back was turned when it started and i
turned i was able to turn around just in
time to see everything hit the [ __ ]
floor
and it looked like it was done by a team
of dudes all acting together it was
weird
yeah because even like the the screw
there or the nails
yeah it's strong it's real strong
but you can't control it
it's just uh
the same thing that girl from [ __ ]
enfield poultry guys case
that girl's weird too
[Laughter]
she is a little bit yeah i don't know
the graphics which is lovely you any any
of you guys
on your you any of your guys in your
unit have like a good gut for something
that's going to happen and then he had
you end up getting a reputation where
like this dude if he says it's going to
happen it's going to happen
most military units have those they had
guys that were really good they put them
out on point
in a vehicle formation because the guy
could sense an ambush
and you could take a picture of it and
there's nothing standing out
you know
and but no the ambush is there but it's
it's concealed you can't see it
but he senses it's there that
other guys can't do it but they did a
damn
the army was doing a test to try to
develop it
that skill from dudes they would show
them through virtual reality goggles
reenactments of ambush and just regular
road
it's not real ambush it's just
recordings of guys in ambush but they're
concealed you can't see them
and some dudes had the ability to
[ __ ] guess
when they were moving into an ambush
zone
far
better than other ones like
it's not random guy had some kind of a
sixth sense to to
predict
when he was going through an ambush even
if it was just an image of an ambush
that's very important it wasn't a real
ambush it was an image of a fake ambush
he seen
but he could detect it
some of the guys
and those guys ended up they would put
those guys in the um
uh in the very front of convoys who
scored high on that a lot of people
don't know about that but that was going
on and i don't know how long that
program went on
that was uh early 2000s they were doing
that the very beginning of the rock war
they talked about it
they declassified that
but i don't know how long they tried to
try to cultivate those guys
now their explanation was is that it
wasn't psychic
they were saying some people have a
subconscious
a very good subconscious that could
recognize a dangerous uh uh situation
i don't know to me that sounds like
psychic to me but
well i mean
maybe one of the same but that's what
i'm saying
maybe it's just like pedantic thing yeah
just the words we're talking about right
oscar says that enfield girl seemed
heavily autistic
she didn't seem like that
well i don't know about her when she was
younger but when you see interviews with
her when she was older she does come
across a little bit like maybe just real
introverted she was afraid to talk maybe
that's what it was yeah she's afraid to
talk about it lee warner says he would
win in a fight captain kirk or han solo
um kirk
i don't know i'd put my money on han
solo no no no because han solo would he
would be restricted to real fighting
captain kirk could use that damn martian
kung fu that he had
no need for me too says kirk has super
ham powers
[Laughter]
yeah he could just go like that and
knock you out
um grant there's hammer that says i
worked with a black fed agent in detroit
for 10 years who always knew what [ __ ]
was fixing to occur i trusted his
instincts completely yeah i kind of feel
like everybody knows somebody like yeah
kayla higgins says random question if
multiverse theory is true
then what do you think your prime
iteration is like considering this isn't
earth 1 or earth prime
there's a real good channel you need to
subscribe to it's called event horizon
guy who runs it's got him john michael
godier is his name
he's got three or four channels but
event horizon is the one where he has a
lot of guests on he talks to astronomers
he has them on and different kind of
physicists
uh some real scientists you know he'll
have that [ __ ] with that uh avi loeb
i think of his name is the guy who's on
the big end of he's from harvard and
he's
saying that he thought that that
um that thing that went through there
was it was
might have been extraterrestrial a piece
of extraterrestrial space junk what was
it the
abuamua
the way it moved and everything wasn't
quite right
but anyway um
he'll have guests on there that'll kind
of call [ __ ] on a lot of advanced
physics
a lot of the stuff in that advanced fit
theoretical physics
was was kind of dreamt up a long time
ago several generations ago a lot of it
and over the years new younger guys have
gotten into that field but they're not
quite as smart as the older guys that
were around a long time ago so they
can't really they can some of them can
grasp
the theory but they can't really improve
on it or build on it
and um there's this in some cases an
element of bullshittery and tomfoolery
in a lot of that advanced physics
because you'll never be able to prove it
or disprove it it's just kind of a
mental or a mathematical
um
[ __ ] gymnastics that you can do on
paper or in your head maybe also some
jiggery pokery jiggery pokery
there's no i would enjoy it there's no
proof of a multiverse
now there might be other universes but
the whole thing about if you move to the
right there's a parallel universe of you
where you move to the left there's
there's no proof of that and you'll
never be able to prove that it's just
theoretical
i mean it's fun to think about yeah
i think there's only one universe that
has us in it
you know what i mean there might be
another universe there is
there is a um
some evidence that
some of these astronomers are saying
that if you look at the fabric of
space-time way out
at the far reaches it looks like maybe
something is slightly
uh pressing on the space-time and maybe
from another direction that doesn't
exist in other words a parallel
dimension is acting on this dimension
and that might be another universe over
there but that's that just theoretical
you'll never be able to go to that other
universe
as far as we know and confirm it
it might be something else it might be
the space time doesn't expand uniformly
here because you can be it can be uh
warped by the presence of things like
dark matter that's another thing
they're taking dark matters right now
it's like it's in vogue to take the
existence of dark matter for granted we
got to figure out where this dark matter
is there are some other guys who are
saying that that dark matter is not
there
uh that it's
it's it's
it's an illusion basically oh this is
the
and i don't he explains it but it was
kind of i remember the ex i don't
remember the explanation
but when he talked about i was like yeah
that's an option too there's another way
to look at that data
you know
some people what's dark matter well the
the universe should be flying apart but
it's being held together by
gravitational forces and there's not
enough mass
in that galaxy to hold it together like
that so there's a bunch of mass missing
where is it there's an there's an
alternate way of looking at that
and i don't remember what it was
[Laughter]
man way to build this up to something
i remember what it was it was it was
complicated because these [ __ ]
are smart you know what i mean
we may be reading it wrong it was but i
don't mean he and he said why
yeah grantham said that there is a
parallel universe so there are
doppelgangers of us living parallel
lives yeah i think that well i mean i
don't know if there are but i think that
that's what people like to think about
because you like to think ooh maybe
right next door
there's another universe where
you know i have bigger boobs or
you know yeah or something you know what
i mean it's like not me
that's not yeah cause you'd be falling
over
[Laughter]
yeah like yeah i want to get a picture
of that my center of gravity is already
kind of [ __ ] up
um now that's like i said go go watch
event horizon
i watch that every one of those like not
the movie but the yeah the the channel
the channel event on youtube
and uh you know he'll sometimes the
shows are an hour two hours long he's
got great guests he has some good
questions
the whole multiverse theory dark matter
type stuff and all the it's all
theoretical
what the practical science
einstein einsteinian stuff has been
confirmed over and over again
even with satellites
those
those satellites are moving fast through
space so they're moving faster through
time
for the gps systems that we use
for them to work we have to we have to
[ __ ]
program those things the clocks to keep
slightly ahead because they're moving
forward through time faster than we are
which is yeah they have to control they
have to compensate yeah it sounds
totally [ __ ] crazy but it's true yep
it is the faster you move through the
fabric of space the fab faster forward
you're moving through time because space
and time are the same thing or there are
different sides of the same thing
it's just that we we evolved
with the senses that we have
and we are making sense out of the
universe through these meager senses
that we have
monkey brains monkey brains so
our personal version of reality is not
accurate in the same way that a slug
it's interpreting reality through its
senses and in its version of reality is
not accurate we're the same way and i
would like to see a slug try to use like
an atm yeah right
well
that's like us trying to figure out the
universe
[Laughter]
we are not equipped to see the universe
as it really is
we don't have a sensory app well that's
why it took so long for us to figure out
like what the universe is you know or at
least get a little grasp of what it's
actually like because it's so
counter-intuitive
to what we would normally
experience in our day-to-day lives and
like i said you know humans don't live a
very long time so we don't really have a
good um like a long-term
uh perspective on things yeah we evolved
to run around on a damn grassland
hunting down gazelles and [ __ ] and
eating them and cooking them
that's that's what what's what we
evolved to do and we have we evolved
with senses
that perceive a world like that
when it comes to
the vastness of space and [ __ ] huge
the a huge universe that's ever
expanding and
space time we're not perceiving it as it
really is
you know there's more to it
but you know what though with our little
dinky ass monkey brains we have figured
out some [ __ ] so in that way like i'm
kind of proud of us probably what will
happen i mean even though we're kind of
idiots relatively we have figured out
some [ __ ]
probably what will happen is we'll make
something kind of like the damn proteus
like out of that demon seed
it'll be so get ready for robot raping
that's what happened to that movie yeah
there's a reason for that
when you go back and look at proteus
though you know i mean it was a super
intelligent
computer of a sentient
and its intelligence was superior to
human beings
eventually we'll make something like
that and it in that computer
and if you could call it a computer it
wouldn't be a computer at that point
it'd be a [ __ ] artificial being or
it'd be a being
yeah at what point does the distinction
between natural and artificial like lose
all meaning it would be a superior being
it was conscious
and it would uh have a much greater
ability to perceive the universe as it
really is
and it would figure all that [ __ ] out
and go back and go okay this is what's
really happening the reason why you
believe in this and that is because you
don't know about this
and this is the way it really is i'm
gonna try to make a model but i can't
make a 3d model because this is
happening in seven different dimensions
at once
but i'll try to map it up so your monkey
braids can kind of understand it okay
let me tell you that's going to go right
yeah
based on what i found out here
i can make a time machine
but i'm not going to give you a time
machine because you all [ __ ] it up
you'll go back and do some [ __ ] we
totally want to say you're not going to
make a time machine for you
it's going to be no time
no time machine for you
i can't make free energy okay and i'm
gonna make you sorry we'll take that
we'll take that and um
that'll help that'll keep you from
[ __ ] [ __ ] up okay so here
plug everything into this box and don't
break it yeah plug everything into this
box and you're good to go
okay
no no reason to burn anything
it's gonna be you know
and then you end up with a civilization
it's kind of like out of the day the
earth stood still remember how [ __ ]
dude shows up with gort because gort you
know
they are our [ __ ] judges and our cops
and law enforcement they make sure we
we're not
[ __ ] the place up but we wouldn't
survive without these things and they
were telling us that you got to go you
all are dangerous we have to [ __ ]
wipe you out you know this is a good
movie it was yeah we should probably do
that since we you know yeah there's
another one i gotta add it's another one
yeah you figured out rocket propulsion
you figure out atomic power and y'all
are [ __ ] dangerous it's time for
y'all to go yeah in a matter of three or
four hundred years you're gonna be a
threat to us so you're you're out of
here yeah so we're just gonna nip it in
the bud right
andy dip it in the bud uh four throw
down said i bet stephen hawking thought
like that all the time he just didn't
type it into a speaking spell yeah
probably poor guy
uh lee warner says which one of the
universal monsters would be the last
monster standing in a fist fight
i want to say probably dracula because
he has like supernatural powers dracula
was smarter than all the rest and he was
smarter than the other ones and like i
said he i mean he had super strength
right
yeah he didn't need to use it
yeah but in a fist fight he would
he could probably just like punch a hole
through
like the gill man
turned into a swarm of bats
or a mist yeah and you'd be like punch
that [ __ ] go underneath your door
so yeah definitely dracula
uh xanada says tell tom i'm drinking
pinnacle peanut butter vodka with grape
juice oh yeah it'd be good how's that
that does taste good actually
yeah see because i don't think that
because i used to work for van gogh
vodka
and i don't even know if they're still
around anymore but if they are they
totally do not make the pb and j vodka
that they because i started working
there like right when they were
introducing that it was good yeah
honestly i really liked it um
you mixed it with
it was pb and j vodka
some raspberry vodka
coke
and then you put like kosher salt around
the rim of the glass and it was really
really good kind of tasted a little bit
like a payday bar but with like a little
bit of a jam type of situation it was
really really good oh tv shows up tina
what the [ __ ]
says hey queen jenny hey how are you i
had a half day off and new job has me by
the balls according to recording so we
know you're secretly a man
all right
that's okay
embrace your masculinity i'm starting
all these i don't know i don't like it
my voice is still kind of [ __ ] up yeah
i don't know
i mean maybe nobody else notices it but
i do i can hear it a little bit it'll
it'll it'll return home i don't like it
it'll return to normal
um you you got more um
volume
you can you use your diaphragm more when
you speak
sound off like you got a pair now
yeah yeah you want more another drink
yeah sure okay
what would you do if i actually did have
a pair i just laughed
would you really yeah
would you accept me for how i was yes
[Laughter]
no he wouldn't
[Laughter]
uh grant us i see that but i'm gonna
wait till tom comes back because i gotta
ask him about that he-man thing
[Laughter]
let's see
i've seen peanut butter whiskey but
never peanut butter vodka i'm not really
sure how many like i said i hadn't heard
about it either but i thought back in
when the [ __ ] did i work at that van
gogh place 2000 god 2013 holy [ __ ] was
it really that long ago okay i think it
was 2013. and they had put out a pb and
j vodka because
i believe it was because pinnacle had
put out a peanut butter vodka and maybe
a couple of other uh ones had to i don't
remember
pinnacle
i don't know how many of them still
carry over nowadays because pretty much
the only ones we buy like pinnacle are
plain
you know
whipped cream sometimes cherry and
sometimes coconut uh sometimes pineapple
um but they have like a bunch of crazy
ass [ __ ] flavors thank you like fruit
loops and
you know yeah what do you do with fruit
loops
throw it in the garbage yeah
i don't even like fruit loops cereal
much less fruit loops vibe get the [ __ ]
out of here with that they have a fruit
loops one and a gummy bear one and i
can't see how that would taste any
different just put them on the grill
yeah no i they i've had them both they
do taste different did they yeah
but i don't know what you would mix them
with
i had them on the rocks they were all
right on rocks i guess maybe that's what
yeah maybe you can't really mix it with
anything i can't really
sparkle myself how gross would it be
i don't know why i just thought of this
how gross would it be to put fruit loops
of vodka and milk in a bowl
and drink it for breakfast
i don't i don't look like cream in it
little shot of cream that well yeah
maybe that's what yeah maybe that's what
i was thinking so maybe if you did put
cream in it it would taste like fruit
loops
uh like cereal with milk in it but boozy
yeah you know what i mean
um wait
what um i was gonna say peanut butter
vodka is good with it is actually yeah
with grape juice it sounds gross but
yeah you like that xanada i i like it i
like it yeah i get the ratio right
i've never had it straight but it's good
mixed with it's really good mixed with
coke and it's really good mixed with
grape juice or grape uh
schnapps because we've done it i've done
that before too i've mixed it with grape
schnapps
but um the weird thing about it was the
the van gogh one was called pb and j and
it had like a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich on the label but
to me it just tasted like peanut butter
vodka i didn't taste any jelly in it and
uh like to make the their signature pb j
drink you had to put raspberry vodka in
it too he said he heard me recommended
on her earlier show he got it online he
says this fire they said i'm telling you
man it's good man now see i haven't
tried the peanut butter whiskey
but i keep seeing it in the store and
i'm like
that sounds really good i mean i like
whiskey i like peanuts how could that
possibly go wrong i mean that's it's got
to be good
granthar says do inanimate objects ever
have power over human actions i offer
justin's he-man as proof
i wanted you to come back before you
before i said that because i wanted you
to
expound upon that
justin t-man are you even listening no
i was reading it at least you invented
it
i was reading i know that face he's like
i know he wasn't listening do inanimate
objects ever have power over human
actions i offer justin's he-man as proof
i don't know
i don't know man i think inanimate
objects have uh have control over
people's actions all the time people are
always [ __ ] doing
justin was possessed by a little damn
mouse it was a little chucky cheese
mouse i think what it was he called it
dwayne paul
his name right into him and he started
sucking his thumb like that and then
[ __ ]
take the [ __ ]
nintendo controller give it to me
so give that [ __ ] back remember how
upset little boys got about about
nintendo i remember my brother getting
like that too
he's an [ __ ]
just stop talking to grandpa
stop talking to dwayne paul hey he had
somebody to talk yeah he'd start cussing
me out and he was like a little kid
is it probably like six that's hilarious
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you say [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] he's wow oh yeah he's uh he's he
was an animal
i didn't tore that house up you know
what's weird is that even though i swear
a lot now
um and i grew up in a family that didn't
really care about swearing yeah i
actually didn't even start swearing
until i was maybe like a teenager like
when i was a little kid i was just kind
of like
i thought i was going to get in trouble
even though i totally wouldn't have
because like my parents wore my
grandparents where everybody's wore they
swore around they didn't give a [ __ ] but
i don't know it took me a long time to
like grow into the swearing i guess
what would you mix peanut butter whiskey
with
peanut butter whiskey i'm not entirely
sure probably be good with um it's
probably gonna cut juice grape juice uh
this is a shot of grape juice and ice or
grape soda
maybe depends on how high quality that
risky is i mean well yeah you'd have to
get rid of you don't miss it with
with you know you know well that's kind
of true of any liquor if it's very high
quality you don't want to mix it with
anything you just want to drink it
straight like on the rocks take it and
take it put it on a rocks and put a shot
of damn
grape juice in it and then taste it and
i bet you it's [ __ ] great what was
that
whiskey that we that we got it was
really good
it wasn't butterscotch it was honey no
not that one
um
i liked that honey one that i had yeah
that was good but that's not what i'm
talking i got that for christmas we had
a whiskey i think it was whiskey
and it was um
when was this
we didn't buy the bottle i don't think
it wasn't cinnamon
no because i would have we were getting
shots out of it at one of these places
um oh it was it we didn't buy it i don't
think so
maybe we did god we drunk so much of it
we were like oh that's pretty good
yeah we had we had the mannequins
they offered it to us oh okay that
little naked girl [ __ ] the naked girl
that girl can't put her clothes on
oh i had to work with chantelle oh i
know she works with chantelle
she can't put her [ __ ] clothes on
maybe she's she's like i can't afford a
lot of clothes i'm just gonna walk
around she
she's into this body painting yeah okay
she'll she'll have if i went to one of
those parties
with a guy i was dating she's a little
cute oh
what time what red
it come back it's coming okay it's
coming yeah all right we're back she's i
got pictures of her i'll show her she's
a little cute
waitress that we know she works at
chantals and she works for big time over
mannequins
and she does these little body painting
[ __ ] um things uh events all the time
tom was like she is she cute and all but
man i can't keep her clothes on
my wife's getting pissed
because his wife's always in there you
know and she she'll walk around naked
she's like a nudist
oh so like actually naked she'll walk
around naked and then [ __ ] then get
painted up and then walk around paint it
up but she'll walk around naked for a
couple hours before i think she might
have like a g-string on and shoes
but i'll show you
people are like no that doesn't happen i
got pictures of it oh it does yeah
she'll put pictures up hold on cheryl
says cinnamon whiskey is so gross yeah i
agree was it cinnamon no no i mean the
weird thing about it is that i love
actual cinnamon i mean cinnamon toast
cinnamon rolls cinnamon anything but i
do not like anything to do with cinnamon
whiskey or anything
really bad heartburn that's her she
can't she can't keep her clothes on
that's right she works at chantelle all
the time yeah she's super cute yeah
what's her name
katie that's right katie katie you're
here i hadn't seen her in a while we
haven't been to shantels in a while yeah
there she's doing
that body painting stuff
damn yeah
they do quite a lot of those body
painting events i went to one well this
was like a long two before we were
together i went to one at some bar
in the milk district
it was a japanese because i remember
drinking sake
so it must have been like a sushi
restaurant or something i don't remember
i was like i wouldn't have been drinking
sake otherwise okay here's a picture of
her walking around without clothes on
but she's painted but she's just
unicorn i'm not lying when i tell you
this [ __ ] unicorn boobies
sparkly yeah
tom's like
i can't get a clothes on man
my wife's getting pissed
he's
we met him at ibarr yeah him and gina
used to come to eye bar every week and
then they were out there dancing
and for as long as we've known him which
is the years and years he always was
like i want to open my own bar when i
get my own bar he's been talking about
it forever so you finally [ __ ] did it
all right look
all right oh and that's carrie and
there's carrie uh
grampus right that's that's jenny
jeffrey's sister
oh we weren't right again
same i'm gonna come on i'm waiting you
might want to keep it up there until
just in case yeah because we're come on
you can do it okay it's coming back it's
coming back all right
grampers
that's jenny jeffrey's sister sister
right there
and and guy nick the person next to me
that's that's big tom yeah he's the one
that owns paint again yeah he owns
mannequins that's my boy
and he is [ __ ] big he's what maybe
six something six on this yeah he's
gotta be at least six four i wanna say
six four
yeah
and that's the inside of mannequins
and that's what
that's called dj
yeah from uh another big dude
venue 13. yeah
yeah see if i can
see if i can find some [ __ ]
funny pictures
zach says if i ever see you guys in real
life i want to meet all these crazy
characters you know yeah
yeah i mean
we're not we're not lying we're not
exaggerating
[Music]
i think i'm [ __ ] he's got something we
got there are some characters around
here that's for sure this is the inside
of manning because this is big tom's
place
that's it
yeah
he wanted me to manage that for him and
i was like dude you don't need me man
[ __ ] you can do that on your own you
got a big old family
looking [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
who is
that i don't know i can't tell it's too
blurry okay
for a second with all that arm waving
around i thought it was me and then i
was just like no i wouldn't dip down
like that because my knees can't take it
i'm too old
yeah hopefully it doesn't glitch out
anymore
that's very annoying when that happens
yeah i mean you know i feel bad we
haven't been able to go to mannequins
but you know we had to buy the house and
then like i was kind of short of money
last month and
you know it was christmas and
[ __ ] man christmas wiped us out because
uh super chat's almost vanished
oh everybody everybody has [ __ ]
christmas you know well that's what i
mean everybody has the same kind
everybody has christmas you know tila
says jen did you review house of the
devil i did a re-watch this week and
watched all of uh ty west stuff i don't
think i've done house of the devil yet
but i do want to get to it eventually
because i really do like that i want to
do the innkeepers as well because i also
really liked that movie and i've seen it
once and i want to do a re-watch on it
but this month i'm doing all folk horror
and
next month i was thinking because it's
march i was thinking about doing like
monster movies but i don't know we'll
see how it goes i'll see what's like
available
at the time i thought it'd be good to do
folklore this month because shutter just
added a whole [ __ ] ton like 50 folk
horror movies
um
zach says if indiana has a goth scene
but you guys are slowly making
what are slowly making want to get
involved in it
i think you left a word out
there or maybe several i'm not entirely
sure um
house is a good take on a slow burn 80s
horror is this the one with uh
with uh william cat because we have
talked about that one
i know there was another one that was
japanese that i think is known more as
hausu
and i want to get to that one too i've
heard that one's weird as [ __ ]
but
i don't know i'll get to like i said i
have so many
it's just all i do because like i said
we have like a bunch of um
you know streaming services and there's
2b and pluto and all that kind of stuff
where you can watch it for free and
sometimes i'll scroll through there like
looking for movies
um you know it's like oh what one do i
want to review next month or whatever
and it's like oh my god there's so many
i was like oh i want to see that oh i
want to re-watch that oh i'm going to
see that oh i remember that movie and
it's just kind of like jesus christ my
tablet is crawling i got to restart it
and [ __ ] clean it oh okay you got to
go through that damn what do you call it
oh is access making me want to get
involved in it okay i should have been
able to figure that out from the context
clues but i'm a little slow on the
uptake
yeah house was so good william uh
william cat and the cheers guy yeah we
did a review of that not too long ago i
mean it was several months several
months ago i think
that was a movie that
i watched a [ __ ] ton like when i was a
kid and the second one too but i
rewatched the second one and i was like
well that was a lot goofier than i
remembered it's still good but it's not
a horror movie it's like more comedy
uh have you guys reviewed color out of
space with nicolas cage yeah pretty sure
yeah we did it yeah we had we have it on
blu-ray so i'm pretty sure we did a
matinee on it it's good like right
around when it first came out on blu-ray
some people didn't like it but i thought
it was pretty good i liked it i didn't
like it quite as much as mandy no man it
was better you know if we're talking
about nicholas cage weird nicholas cage
movies mandy worked i mean as far as
lovecraftian adaptations go i think it's
definitely one of the best lovecraft
adaptations i mean it really has a love
crafty vibe to it
let's see it again so i did like that
yeah it was i thought we'd seen it twice
well no i guess we did just watch it i'm
gonna do a smart cleaning can we like
can we talk about the movie that we
watched last night like the premiere or
well we know we're gonna review oh we're
gonna do a review on it yeah so there
was a movie that we plug it
yeah you know
well one of our uh listeners what's his
what's his name do we know brian um yeah
brian
brian hackett yeah um he works in the
movie industry yeah i went to school
with him yeah with the same uh we went
the same military cabinet uh
academy together some california
military academy and he worked on a film
he worked on a bunch of films well he's
worked in a bunch of philadelphia but he
was a crusade yeah
he worked on a film that uh had its
world premiere on youtube yeah last
night last night
so we watched the live premiere so we'll
probably we'll talk about it on sunday
yeah it's called shut in it's called
shut in you
i recommend it it's good you can go
watch it it's like a psychological
horror
yeah film
horror drama
i guess
he uh also worked on uh vfw
he worked on uh
[ __ ] a bunch of them that i liked
was the other one [ __ ]
some of them i reviewed i didn't even
know he was i didn't know he did him
yeah he's been on it he's been done
and um
he's uh
uh
he's working his his the studio he works
for is working for daily wire it's not
and uh he did the uh he did
this one
i think he did uh
he did the one what was it [ __ ]
uh did run hide fight i don't know if he
did that one
and then the one about the
anyway he he did the tear around the
prairie too it is not out yet the gina
chrono flick
oh yeah tila just reminded me that uh ty
west also did the sacrament which was
also very good that was essentially just
the jonestown case except
modernized and slightly fictionalized
but not that much uh but yeah that was
uh that was good yeah
he has a new movie coming out called x i
think
um zach says can you guys put me in
touch with brian i love talking with
film people
talking to time
zack is uh no
you're so mean
he if he sho if he shows up in the
comment section you can talk to him but
i can't just send people at him
it's not professional
i mean yeah we'll see
john gorra says you should do the 1971
french film don't deliver us from evil
it's kind of like heavenly creatures it
was banned in france apparently
ooh all right i'm gonna write that down
because
i don't think i've ever seen that but i
had did see heavenly creatures but
all right don't deliver us from evil
and then dj maniac says
i watched a weird one last week it's
called we need to do something i keep
seeing that one come up
because i think it's on shutter or
amazon prime and i keep seeing that
goodbyes like oh yeah i need to watch
that one of these days um
if it's weird i kind of want to watch it
though so i'm going to write that down
i think it's on shutter
because i think i saw it earlier when i
was watching a field in england
so
do do do
zach is trying to get work as a
cinematographer
putting his work out there with local
filmmaking groups
so they're saying the trailer for the
new ty west movie looks really good so i
need to like look that up because i
don't think i've seen the trailer yet
and i did i have seen all those other
movies and i liked them so
i'm gonna write that down too
because otherwise if i don't write stuff
down i won't remember
krampus says tom
putin said today that if ukraine joins
nato he will go nuclear should we start
digging underground bookers no
no
i think um
i'm still reading
trying to catch up on the comments
i think that whole i think that whole um
now
i don't have any inside information i'm
just of course i'm just looking at it
from the outside
i think that whole um
ukraine thing is [ __ ] [ __ ] i
think it's already kind of a done deal
they already know what's gonna happen
um
it wouldn't surprise me if if russia
takes half of ukraine
but you have to understand that
russia itself was a project of ukraine
that's kind of where
russia started
back hundreds of years ago it's kind of
like saying
philadelphia oh that's not america
you know
it's just that during during the breakup
of the soviet union [ __ ]
certain republics or certain states went
rogue
and also they changed hands through a
bunch of different ethnic groups that
had happened in ukraine ukraine was
always disputed territory it's like a
[ __ ] badlands it's it's kind of
lawless it was uh
being fought over by basically the
remnants of the [ __ ] nazis of
ukrainian type nazis
um [ __ ] tartars and a bunch of other
people
and it's just kind of like a
a wild
buffer state it's just you know to keep
rush to keep people off of russia's
border
but it was it was always a part of
russia until recently in terms of you
know in a historical sense
uh
no one's attacking anybody russia hasn't
done anything if anything nato's moving
in on russia the only thing that putin
is saying is do not put missiles on our
[ __ ] border which we would do the
same thing so nothing unusual is
happening it's a distraction
they just want to make money so same
[ __ ] american
corporations trying to make money and
trying to
have a distraction they're just trying
to distract from what's happening in
canada it's all full of [ __ ] they're
full of [ __ ]
i don't think anything's gonna happen
russia's gonna get his land back and
then we're gonna cry
that's all
john goris uh brings up the movie we
need to talk about kevin i actually did
do a review of that i haven't read the
book but
i feel like for a while
there was like a whole sub genre of
books that were kind of like
psychological horror that were kind of
like a from a parent's point of view
it's like oh hey my kid's a psychopath
or i hate my kids
and i'm here for it i i really kind of
like books like that i don't know why um
one of the best ones i read but like
that was called baby teeth which was
about
uh a mom who had a daughter who was just
the [ __ ] worst uh which is very very
good if you haven't read it but one of
these days i need to read the book we
need to talk about kevin but the movie
is actually really really good tilda
swinton is in it
and uh that's it's about a woman whose
son is a school shooter so grantham says
man if the russians get in there house
[ __ ]
how's that going to affect the porn
industry
oh man it's just everybody's dying to
get out of ukraine it's [ __ ] poor you
know it's [ __ ]
this place is in rough condition and
zach's going some of them ukrainians
want to be independent
everybody [ __ ]
wants to be independent from whatever
empire is claiming them none of that
[ __ ] is decided until it's decided by
the [ __ ] gun
politics is just combat by any other
means it's warfare by other means and
when all the means are [ __ ] dried up
it always gets down to the gun
it's going to be decided soon it
force always decides it
now force comes in a bunch of different
forms doesn't have to be shooting i mean
as we can see now
guns and bombs aren't really the best
way to go right now the way it goes
trucks
there's no defense against trucks
you can [ __ ] up people's minds with a
truck
warfare has evolved
a lot
it's not like it was back when the white
boys put on these white wigs and went
and claimed somebody's capital i have
not i have occupied the building so
therefore i'm in charge like some [ __ ]
on it that went out the window in world
war ii people have to [ __ ] kind of
adjust their
their thinking you know everything is
asymmetric
and optics
you know
caitlyn higgins says have you read any
uh genji ito short stories i have not
although it is on my list i have seen a
lot of movies that were based on his
stuff like uzumaki and stuff like that
um but i do actually want to get back to
the source material at some point uh
jenny have you heard of or read the book
cows probably the most disturbing book
ever i have heard about it and it is on
my list is it anything i kind of felt
like
um
[Music]
i don't know like i i got the impression
that it was kind of like that book
tender is the flesh which i did review
which was about humans being processed
like cattle like for
meat
um
and
that's some [ __ ] that's some [ __ ]
vore fantasy there
it's really not though because it's
disgusting
it's one of the most disgusting things
i've ever read
although it didn't make me want to stop
eating meat though
you know what i mean some people like i
read reviews and they're like well i'm
done with meat now like after reading
that no and i was like no it is
disturbing i will say that the book is
disturbing but it's basically like in a
future where like some virus or
something like wipes out animals and
people still want meat so they decide
they're going to breed like a subclass
of humans
like to make meat out of no it's it's a
parable like a george orwell type of
thing um and so it goes very very in
depth about how the humans are processed
through the thing
and uh yeah it's i mean it has a story
and stuff too like i said it's very or
it's very george orwell i really liked
it it's really really good it was a good
book the whole anti-meat thing is a
political thing and it's more of a mind
[ __ ] than anything else
if
if they could [ __ ]
if cloning technology gets good enough
where you could just damn clone a steak
half of a [ __ ] piece of beef and
that's cheaper and better meat and you
can it's cheaper because you can have a
lot of it in one area and it's not
grazing
that'd be the way to go i'd eat it
yeah i would too i eat that yeah i'm not
bothered no honestly it's it doesn't
have to come from an actual animal in
fact it would make me feel better if it
was some cloned piece yeah if it was
just if they just cloned a steak like
and they didn't have to kill like an
actual cute little cow yeah then yeah
although the the animals that had bread
been bred for slaughter even the
intelligent ones they're weird you know
i mean i've dealt with them before
like
okay let me give an example i couldn't
eat a cat especially a pet cat or a pet
dog
even a dog that's not a pet
you see the koreans and the chinese they
got damn dogs and cages and [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] boiling them alive and
[ __ ] just inhumane [ __ ] right i can't
understand it
i guess only sociopaths and psychopaths
[ __ ] survive the [ __ ] cultural
revolution over there because i don't
understand how you couldn't have empathy
for those animals all right
eating an animal like that especially
one that's bred more of us more as a
servant than food
you know
and they're obviously the animals are
under [ __ ] tremendous tremendous
stress including the cats sitting there
they're drooling from fear because
they've seen what happens to the other
cats
yeah because they're not dumb yeah
they're not dumb and they're they have
not been bred for slaughter
pigs on the other hand a very [ __ ]
different thing man you can [ __ ] grab
a pig
from a whole [ __ ]
group of pigs
slaughter that pig
in front of [ __ ] pigs that are
related to it
and they won't even stop eating
well maybe they're just like glad it
wasn't me today yeah and then you can
cook the pig
and they start begging for the food give
me some eggs give me some of that and
you can [ __ ] throw some of that pig
and they'll eat it they've totally
forgotten about it
and it's because they were bred in
captivity they were bred for slaughter
and these are intel pigs that haven't
have an intelligence are actually very
intelligent but they're just not acting
like a normal animal a normal animal
would not well because they're not
raised in normal circles they're not
raised in normal circle and it's
genetics
the pig that behaved normally ended up
being weeded out of the [ __ ] breeding
stock because they were too difficult to
manage
the ones that were subservient and could
deal with that kind then they just ended
up the ones they were the ones that were
bred in
so they just don't have any defensive
instincts about
being eaten
now wild pig would but i'm talking about
the domestic pigs i've seen that with
domestic pigs give me some of that give
me some of that you can [ __ ] okay
you're like damn that was your mom but
they just don't have that it's just not
in them they don't they're like a robot
in that in that in that
aspect but a dog i don't think would do
that
i don't think a cat would do that
cats understand that
because they're more like a wild animal
they're more like a normal animal
now whenever i hunted
you're always culling
when you're hunting
you've built a paradise to attract deer
from other hunters but you can't bait
which that's
grafters he's a he's the ex-game warden
he knows exactly i'm talking about you
can plant their natural
food
okay
but you can't hang out
put a bunch of apples out there in a
basket and shoot [ __ ] deer that are
coming that's bathing you know also it's
kind of like cheating right but the idea
is is to build a [ __ ] wonderland that
you have hunting rights on and have all
the rye grass and you have acorns and
the [ __ ] that they like
and you you let them come in and you let
them breed in large numbers
okay so you're creating deer
and then you call out
the males the older males you want them
to be about three or four years old so
in other words you know
six points
eight point deer like that
you don't want to do first year second
year deer nah go for the guys that got
rex and then on doday you take out the
older does
but you want your does they're the ones
that are making deer so you're culling
you've just taken the job of predator
you know what i mean which would be a
mountain lion the mountain lions are
gone
and if you don't do that you'll have too
many of them they'll deplete the food
supply and you're the ones that provided
the food supply anyway you planted all
that
see in a way
you're providing them with a natural
life that's the life that they have in
nature you've just taken the place of
the mountain lion
and you're trying to create gardening
for them
and you do this on land you have hunting
rights on
so your hunters are actually making deer
they're not killing deer they're making
them
if good hunters move in your deer
population is going to start
skyrocketing and they're going to eat
culling off the top of them
and they live as a normal deer
as a wild deer and they die as a wild
deer
and it's a single shot right to the
[ __ ] chest bam they don't even know
what hit them
now the only time i've ever seen a deer
[ __ ] know that something got him
this
bow day i i i'll bring my bow up here
i'll show you the deer the bow that i
used to use my dad gave it to me
it's a high country
you can hit him with a bow and they'll
jump up about three feet and run and
then they'll come right back to the spot
where you hit them and they'll sniff the
ground what was that and they don't know
it but a damn broadhead's gone right
through them
and in the state of mississippi we use
poison pods
that way there's no chance of survival
and they start buckling and they go to
sleep
and it doesn't seem to be painful they
just don't know what that was
so i don't feel sorry for them now
cattle
domestic cattle
they're living in a damn concentration
camp basically well the slaughterhouse
is not a concentrate they're not really
living in that they're living in
pastures they go to a slaughterhouse and
they're just [ __ ] they're knocked off
quickly
um they're usually killed by a [ __ ]
basically a [ __ ] spike gun to the
head
blows it through there the pneumatic
pressure pow it gets them instantly
but i've seen some slaughter techniques
that didn't looks humane to me driving
them through a [ __ ] their head
through an opening and a blade come and
cut their throat and then they run away
that didn't look too cool to me
or uh
hanging sheep up by the back leg and
cutting the throat there's another one
that those are old videos they probably
don't know if they do that anymore um
that was in islam they would call it
halal slaughter
but there's faster ways you know
i really don't like the idea of having
to like string up any animal because
you're prolonging their fear and their
suffering yeah you want to want to knock
them out quick they don't i mean you
want yeah you just want them not even to
know what happened to them yeah ideally
right and
some of the
they do have good methods i just don't
know which methods are being used by
west slaughterhouse you know what i mean
each company is going to do it
differently
but
it's probably all as humane as it can be
usually
because there's people that there's
government agencies that go in there and
see what they're doing
i saw something up here some of the
stuff that's kind of questionable is
raising chickens in such a small area
that's weird
another one is uh chinese fish farmers
they'll have a [ __ ] hundred fish in a
damn
55-gallon oil drum
filled with water they're in that oil
drum the lid on it they can't get out
and it's they're aerating it and they're
in total darkness
and they're pouring
antidepressants and [ __ ]
drugs in there
to keep those fish calm and they've
never [ __ ] seen sunlight
and they're just packed in there
in a damn drum
that's spooky [ __ ] when you think about
it yeah i mean
that's the thing i'm not averse to
eating meat i'm just saying that if
you're going to raise animals for food
let them live at least let them live
like a normal and
when you slaughter them for food like
let them not know what happened right
yeah i mean that's ideal that's right
that's that's the way i believe too i
don't want them to suffer yeah but the
the fish thing keeping the fish in the
barrel kind of weirded me out they
didn't seem right
they're trying to get a maximum amount
of fish in a minimum amount of space
and they're drugging those fish to keep
them calm in that water and they're just
blasting it which is dumb because it's
like look the money you're spending on
the drugs to keep the fish calm why
don't you get like a bigger barrel and
like have a better setup they've worked
it out they've had well evidently but
they've worked it out that that seems
really stupid to me per square inch
that's the cheapest way and the best way
and the quickest way to get and it's
tilapia they're doing that to salafia
that's the one that's where tilapia come
from which is a very cheap fish very
cheap fish at least in the u.s come out
of a damn drum
maybe we shouldn't buy that anymore now
that we but not that we buy it that much
anyway but yeah
uh caitlyn higgins talking about
plant-based meats honestly i've had um i
kind of like that a lot of fast food
places now are even like offering like a
plant-based hamburger if you want that
i've had the uh the plant-based whopper
what do they call it the impossible
whopper not bad not bad
it was actually pretty good it was
actually pretty good yeah you know
tina says she never had venison it's
it's good
it's very lean
yeah i mean you gotta know how to cook
it
xanada yeah i was thinking this too
santa said tom said fish are like robots
in a previous show yeah
i think they are but
i didn't well when i was talking about
the [ __ ] drum
i didn't i didn't condemn it i just said
it weirded me out that's kind of weird
they are kind of like robots
but should a robot live like that
you know that's what i mean and honestly
it's
even if they're not even if they're not
all that aware of what's going on it's
like i still don't think it's right like
to make them live in a way that's like
really constrictive and really like
where they're suffering if you have to
give them drugs because they're like
freaking out
then obviously that's not
conducive to their welfare the thing is
those are they suffering or is it more
like they're in a state where they've
never really been born
i mean does it matter though i mean from
our like
because they've never really from the
point of view of our quote-unquote
superior intellect yeah yeah to me it
just seems like well let's try to like
replicate their natural environment
that's what i would do as much as
possible yeah you know within our means
in mississippi what we would do is we'd
get a bulldozer and we'd [ __ ] dig a
big i mean it seems like common sense
yeah we get a bulldozer
if your friend has a bulldozer when he's
not working you have him cover you pay
for the fuel and you say i'm gonna give
you some fish and he'll come and he'll
cut a big [ __ ]
square in the ground a giant square and
then you just fill it up with water
okay and then you seed it with catfish
and [ __ ]
uh bluegill and uh brim
and you'll have a whole bunch of fish
and you can go in there and fish them
they have they have companies that'll
come and they'd
they'd seed it you know it'd stock it up
with fish
the birds come and bring there's some
algae you can put in there to grow and
then we throw whole loaves of bread
[ __ ] whole [ __ ] things a damn
cattle feed corn and [ __ ] no eat all
that the whole water would just explode
the fish trying to [ __ ] attack every
time you throw the damn corn feet corn
feed in there they [ __ ] love it
and you get [ __ ] you could feed
[ __ ] seven eight nine families on
that on that thing for [ __ ] years and
years before you had to restock it
that's what i mean that's how you do it
that's some sustainable [ __ ] right there
and the fish are having like a normal
fishy life yeah normal fish like and
then the birds are bringing fish new
you're catching fish that you didn't
stock you're like man that's a [ __ ]
bass how'd that get in there cause the
birds brought it yeah
bringing in [ __ ] eggs and their
[ __ ]
fish eggs get stuck in their
feathers they land in there and
transport and [ __ ] fish from one pond
to the next
yeah that's what i mean i just kind of
feel like if you're gonna do that that's
why i'm all for like [ __ ] sustainable
farming like all that kind of stuff just
make
everything as
i'm not averse to eating meat like i
said
um but
you should at least strive to
make the conditions as close to their
natural condition well it's in a
relationship as a trade yeah you're
allowing the animal to live sometimes
longer than they would live in the wild
yeah and and they're not having us
struggle for survival and then they pay
you back in the end for us
in meat
and uh you're giving them a you're
giving them a humane death because in in
the wild they're eating alive
like deers that's why deer are eating
alive yeah and dogs right and wolves and
[ __ ] so we should give them like a
greater like we're eating them so you
should give them like some respect you
know what i mean and like you said they
have in a lot of ways they might have a
better life than they would have in the
wild because they don't get you know
eaten a lot at least they get taken out
humanely and don't even know what
happened to them you know what i mean i
don't have a problem with that at all
uh wading birds like egrets transport
fish eggs in their webbed feet says
grampur's hammer yep
uh jenny do you think it would be hard
for you to go vegetarian yes i was
vegetarian for a couple of years
in my twenties
i didn't find it all that difficult but
after a while i was just like meh i
don't know i just i kind of wanted a
steak
honestly it would be and oh it's my
creepy yeah that [ __ ] creepy phone my
creepy phone
um
nowadays it would probably be much
easier like when i did it it was in the
90s
and there really weren't a lot of
options for vegetarians or vegans um in
the sense that i mean now
[ __ ] like i said you can go to like a
fast food place and get a plant-based
burger like no problem at all back in
the 90s not so much it was still
considered kind of weird so
much harder
um it'd be easier nowadays but i don't
know
i don't know i don't know if i would
want to or not
it does bother me i don't really like
eating cute animals but um that's kind
of why i'm sort of on board i know some
people don't like gmos and stuff but
i'm kind of like if they can grow like
cloned meat
that's just the same as regular meat and
they don't have to kill you know cows or
chickens or whatever then
i'll eat it
i'm not bothered
um you know it's it's win-win for me you
get actual meat but you don't have to
actually kill an animal to do it so to
me that's a win-win
i'm not really worried about health
effects or anything like that it's it
doesn't bother me all that much
cloning is not that weird to me
um
xanada said i thank god my girlfriend is
a meat-eater i won't date another
vegetarian
like i said it is much easier to be a
vegetarian or vegan nowadays i mean i
think back to
the 80s and the 90s and i knew some
people that were vegetarians and i tried
to go and i went vegetarian for a couple
of years too and it's very difficult it
was very difficult back then you just
you know now you can just go to a
grocery store or restaurant or
everything everybody has vegetarian
options and vegan options
but back then that was not the case so
you really had to like you know you'd go
to a restaurant and like the only
literally the only thing you could eat
was like a salad with no dressing on it
it's like you could even have the
dressing because it had anchovies in it
you know what i mean so it's like
it's like gee i can have like a tiny
little salad with no dressing and maybe
some mashed potatoes
or if you're a vegan maybe not because
maybe they put milk in it so
it's you know it's much much easier
nowadays so maybe i can swing it
nowadays but i would probably
not uh yeah tila says the thing about
eating plant-based for about a month is
once you smell bacon cooking it's a
struggle
yeah there's really i mean i'm sure
it'll get better
it has gotten better because you know
some of the plant-based
um
burgers that i ate back like frozen
burgers and stuff like that like some of
them are okay but
they didn't really taste like meat like
the it's not so much the taste it's the
texture the texture is not exactly meat
like and it's a little off-putting
um but they've gotten a lot better in
that regard
nowadays i mean i haven't really had a
lot of like i haven't any tofurky or
anything like that
but i don't mind um
[Music]
meat substitutes in things like if you
want to make like a spaghetti sauce that
has tofu in it or something like that
where it wouldn't really but i don't
want to eat like a block of the [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying because the texture
it's just it's not right
i've had vegan hot dogs
which are
fine if you put a lot of stuff on them
like you know ketchup mustard
mayonnaise pickles relish whatever
um
but it's still a little
mushy
so you know that it's not quite right
it's getting better though i will say
it's getting better it's not a huge
difference it's not like it used to be
where
you know you get like these weird like
tofu soy burgers and stuff like that and
they were just like really really weird
now it's
getting close
it's it's pretty similar that ice
machine is still kicking ass is it yeah
cheryl did you buy one of those ice
machines oh she's got that ice machine
don't you
who was that there was another cheryl
asking for asking about the ice machine
huh um
no it was somebody on instagram
i thought that was cheryl no it was
somebody from australia vashti somebody
um
tayla says i eat mostly plant-based with
a little fish and poultry no desire for
anything else right now things may
change later and we're allowed that yeah
i mean you know that's fine i don't i
won't i don't judge anybody for you you
know you just eat what you want man
don't like work either goes ice machine
don't make a thing about it yeah we
bought a desktop ice machine
for upstairs so we don't have to go all
the way downstairs to get ice out of
them and a refrigerator
we have a mini fridge and a desktop ice
maker yeah right there in the next room
yeah
i should have got the red one but i got
the silver one it's it's like that big
it's about that tall and it's got
buttons on the top of it and a little
lid you opened up
and what you do is you take filtered
water because i filter my water you take
that and you pour about a gallon of it
into there
and it starts making ice and throwing it
into a
and it'll sit there and you can select
what size ice you want
and uh and it goes through the whole
processes it makes ice people want
little ice cubes big ice cubes and it'll
keep up with us
two people drinking it'll continue to
make ice
and that way i don't have to
i got ice trays but man
for that little bit i use those during
the day like to put in my water
because i drink ice water all day long
got an automatic ice maker downstairs
and that
in the fridge in the fridge but man i'm
getting sick of [ __ ] going down there
and getting knives so then i started to
go all the way downstairs [ __ ] that
remember the ice bucket i got sick of
the ice bucket well i repurposed the ice
bucket and now i put like i lined like
it was a plastic bag and now i keep my
coffee creamer in it because i have a
coffee pot in here so i have a coffee
creamer in there it tells you when the
water gets low so you just grab your
pitcher out of the out of your water
pitcher filter water and take it out of
the dam refrigerator and pour it right
on top of the ice it goes through the
ice through the ice basket down in the
reservoir and just makes continues to
make ice and when it fills up it stops
it'll just sit there with the ice in it
tammy says
i have the same ice machine and copper
yeah
you probably should have got the red one
i was looking the other day
it's silver it's silver yeah they
actually have a really nice i was
looking on amazon they actually have a
really snazzy retro looking mini fridge
that's bright red and also they have a
really swanky
toaster oven yeah like and convection
thing
that's bright red i think it's eighty
dollars but it's super fancy also says
tom return it for the freaking red one
i want to get the red one too
because if we have parties up here
i'll run these ice machines see
yeah and everybody just gets that
because you know
i don't think my refrigerator could
[ __ ] fuel a whole damn party not with
these [ __ ]
yeah like i said it is kind of nice
having this up because honestly it's not
just you know
alcohol
you know my office is up here and i
drink ice water all day
and it's kind of a pain like every time
i drink my glass of ice water to go all
the way downstairs to get more ice and
then come all the way back up so it's
nice to just go in the next room and
there's ice and i can put water in this
is what danny says tom get one of those
stair chair lists for seniors says
well that'd be cool man to get on there
because because the the stairwells i
don't know if it will work because it's
not straight all the way down it goes
down
and that goes like that they got those
did they they got this all rich people
have those so they come down here like
that and be like i'm rich sitting on
there she's talking to that's right she
i don't even have to walk down the
street he's watching that [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ] is this
who can't get on it and ride down this
side around my [ __ ] lap [ __ ]
riding down the stairs
[Laughter]
i'm just trying to think about what
pookie would think about that she i she
would totally get in the chair and like
ride up and down the stairs i feel like
peppa pig pob says tom's been 338 days
since i bought my silencer still don't
have it it's just crazy
i also put my water through a berkeley
filter
and have an ice maker that i power with
solar when i was is a solar powered ice
maker i'm gonna call [ __ ] on that
dude i've never heard of a solar-powered
ice mega i thought there was solar
powered everything well maybe it's just
another ice maker but he's got a solar
bank so you can put outside it's a
pretty big [ __ ] solar thingy you know
what i mean you put the forgot the cell
you got that big old about the size of
an old pc
they're about i think they're about
thirteen fourteen hundred dollars
they're pretty nice to have but i got so
many generators
but you know what i mean if you ever run
out of fuel you could use that but
i got the little
solar charging banks for small stuff
like for your
cell phones cell phones i got that
uh all my flashlights have a solar panel
in them
and it's pretty good flashlights got
three of those
somebody was talking about like do you
remember back in the old days we're
still like spoiled now like yeah we have
a desktop ice machine it was cheap too
it wasn't all that expensive
and uh you know you just pour water and
it makes ice and back in the old days
they didn't have a refrigerator they had
an ice box you had to have the ice man
bring a big [ __ ] block of the [ __ ]
and put it in the ice box and then you
put your food in there like keep it cool
so there's this solar powered a
solar-powered ice maker for camp and i
ain't buying it
i don't know like i said i've seen solar
power
way you just put it in your rucksack
yeah right put it in your sleeping bag
zaneta said i've seen uh foreigners talk
about how they don't understand
americans obsession with ice drinks but
i love eyes too i just i guess it's just
because it's addictive
yeah well it's all in what you're used
to like what you grew up with like in
the uk
um if you well like if you go to like a
fast food place because i went to some
fast food places in the uk they they
give you a drink with like just like
normal
but um you know as far as i knew it's
like i didn't have to ask for anything
special but they're just not used to and
it's cold there most of the time
so it's like most of the time they want
some hot tea or they just want you know
but in florida particularly it's [ __ ]
hot as balls down here god damn it yes
room temperature room temperature i
don't want to be drinking [ __ ] room
temperature [ __ ] come on room
temperature in the honky motherland is
like [ __ ] 60.
60 degrees fahrenheit that's [ __ ]
cold pretty chilly
you know [ __ ]
so it's not the same here room
temperature
in florida is 97 fahrenheit yeah if we
didn't have the air on could be 97 it
would be like 100 degrees in the [ __ ]
house 97 [ __ ] in the summer
humidity yeah
i couldn't even sleep maybe we had to
get on the ground remember when they had
we had that storm well we not only had
to get on the ground we had to fill the
bathtub up with ice and then lay in the
bathtub yeah
yeah let me get in the bed i still
couldn't sleep get in the bathtub and
cool off for a few seconds then get out
[ __ ] it all cold and [ __ ] throw
yourself on the ground
oh it's bad
yeah cause it's like i don't want any
blankets touching my body
it was bad
muggy hot
so i don't want any fabric touching me
i'm
i mean we're southern but we're [ __ ]
modern southerners you know i mean from
the from the era of [ __ ]
air conditions yeah air conditioning
[ __ ] i don't really that old school
white trash those [ __ ] are just
damn leave the windows open the [ __ ]
bugs and come in
hot as a [ __ ] they might have
screens and a fan
but it was 100 degrees in there man 100
degrees with [ __ ] 100 humidity and
they'd be totally comfortable
like it was no big deal i remember it
was a kid
also you might have one room that was
air conditioned maybe they were
psychopaths they might have one room
there they'd have a window unit in one
room where their bedroom was well that's
what my grandma's house was built in
1958 yeah it was built in daytona beach
it was built with and not daytona beach
it wasn't on the uh
coastal side it was on the mainland like
on the other side of the river so it was
actually in holly hill
so it was built in 1958 with zero air
conditioning because they didn't build
things with air conditioning in 1958 and
floor even in [ __ ] florida
she actually had a window unit installed
later in the 60s or the early 70s and it
was only in one room it was in the
dining room like right by the back
screen door
so in the summer time
the back bedrooms because there were
three bedrooms in the back
um you couldn't sleep back there yeah it
was like 100 degrees so everybody had to
we did we would just put like a quilt
down in the
in the formal living room which is right
across from the dining room and
everybody would just sleep in there yeah
in the summer my my buddy khan avatsalon
has just showed up we're talking about
how hot it is he's in tijuana gone you
guys do you guys have air conditioning
or you guys with that aztec bloodlines
you're just so hardcore that you don't
need like [ __ ] air conditioning it's hot
but the thing is is mexico i would think
mexico would be dry
and dry heat is so it's different so
much intolerable i love dry heat but
with [ __ ] 100 humidity it's [ __ ]
miserable
miserable well yeah we've said this
before it's like it's like walking
through hot soup it's like being wrapped
in plastic
the uh the the only it's a natural
barrier to keep out yankees all right
that's the best thing about it the only
thing though is that in mississippi we
have immigration in mississippi number
one immigrant mississippi the vietnamese
they love it they love it there it's
like the mekong delta
well yeah the the same weather the
climate is very same weather
so they're like hey just like
home my dad's generation
there's a lot of vietnamese in orlando
too did you know that my dad's
generation all your commercial fishermen
down in the delta region and then in the
rivers they were all basically anglo
irish descent with some german you know
they're like my me they're like me
uh now it's all vietnamese they're down
in there man they're tearing it up all
right and the game wardens had to get
them right about hey you know there's
laws here you can't just do this [ __ ]
you know because they'll just fish
something to extinction it's just about
money for them
but evidently they've made the they've
made the uh
they made the [ __ ] um
what do you call it
conversion into [ __ ]
into [ __ ] uh uh nature conservation
you know if that if not they go to jail
but uh no the vietnamese are [ __ ]
fantastic fishermen
you just gotta watch them they'll get
into an area and they'll just [ __ ]
fish it out
well because destroyer it's there yeah
they're like we're gonna fish all this
[ __ ] you know
which uh thinking that that kind of
thinking went out with the depression
you know
which i understand why during the
depression era in that area people were
just so desperate for food they would go
in there and they would just wipe out an
entire population of any kind of animal
and that's really when game wardens
started
if you guys are into the [ __ ]
predator series with the when the damn
predator game warden shows up all that
game warden mentality came from the
depression era when people decided that
well we're gonna go out and [ __ ] kill
all these animals
not to feed ourselves but to feed all
these other families and we'll make a
whole bunch of money off of it
that's commercial hunting that's not the
same
that's commercial
so
you can't do that without a license any
and and commercial fishing and
commercial hunting
you can't that's not an unlimited
resource you can't go out there it's
just [ __ ] unlimited you know what i
mean you you'll kill every [ __ ] deer
in the whole state then there won't be
any deer
you know
but people were worried about short-term
problems
well i think that's one of human's big
downfalls is that we can only see things
like i said we don't live very long in
the grand scheme of things so we only
see things like in the short term lars
ulrich says i'm in the honky motherland
and i can't wait to see the sun
well see that just goes to show how your
perspective can change because i grew up
in florida my whole life and [ __ ] man
i'm so sick of looking at the [ __ ]
sun
that i could scream honestly like if
it's when it's raining and cloudy
outside i i'm like ooh like i want to go
outside and run around in it when it's
cold and stuff when it's sunny i'm like
[ __ ] it i'm not going outside today i
lived all over the all over
all over the world and enjoyed almost
every place i was in
egypt brazil korea
california mississippi florida michigan
boston
new york
i liked all of it it all every one of
those areas had good things about it
well yeah everywhere it is we all do
everywhere it is every one of those
places had [ __ ] bad things about it
it's always a mix everywhere it is
florida i love florida i wasn't born
here i wasn't raised here i moved here
later in life
uh
louisiana love losing i call louisiana
because y'all are foreigners it's
louisiana it's not louisiana but
louisiana if i said louisiana in front
of my dad he [ __ ] smack me
what the [ __ ] yeah wait you need to be
like that you know
what
there's no such thing as a lunch it's
always dinner all right dead or a supper
all right [ __ ] that's the mentality
but anyway um
jenny's
connor takes florida for granted
what kind of floor because i was born
she was born here i love florida florida
has a lot of good
things about it oh i recognize that
florida reminds me
of oceanside california back in the 70s
san diego in the 70s
that's what it's like it was like that
back in it and it kind of like and that
was kind of like the good old days of of
cal southern california kind of like
that
but the thing is is southern california
is a desert
the weather was [ __ ] great okay
uh
florida is [ __ ] dagobah all right
it's a swamp it's hot in it and it's
either hot swamp
or hot forest
with pine trees
or hot cattle ranch
around this house is a bunch of cattle
ranches
cows
and [ __ ] horses and [ __ ]
well it actually didn't see any cows and
it's just big open
pastures i don't know where the cows
there are cows though they're cows in
there but they're probably like [ __ ]
probably although it's it's not that hot
nowadays yeah i think today it was in
the 60s i think it got up to 69 today
yeah winter time it's nice fahrenheit
rest half the year it's [ __ ] it's 90
to 100 more than half of the year it's
well not only is it
you just it's it's so [ __ ] humid
you're just constantly damp you can't
ever get dry
um but also we have like hurricanes
there's so it's either like super super
hot and humid or
you're getting blown away by hurricanes
or tornadoes and you have to plan for
hurricanes oh and flooding we
and sinkholes because they're i've been
through
two of them now and one of them we were
out of power for almost a week wouldn't
it
it was a while four days i mean and man
in the heat and that hot muggy heat
that's [ __ ] not man it's terrible
definitely
terrible
um
so civilization can end at any moment we
don't the power grid there's certain
things you know what i mean if you're in
california and new york you think of an
an indestructible uh
civilization where nothing can it'll
always be here you can depend on it not
in the south
not the south hurricanes [ __ ] take
care of all that hurricane can just
if a hurricane were to hit new york it
would destroy new york okay so it's not
just what we make it's
those areas have built up over the years
because they didn't have things like
hurricanes hitting them
exception would be california
california's been hit by earthquakes but
that always bounces back
um well we do too we bounce back too
just and it takes a while because
sometimes hurricanes will wipe out whole
cities yeah
but you know yeah people don't
understand what happened i lived through
katrina i was living in louisiana when
that happened and i was working for a
company that supported the uh
uh um
louisiana state police
and
katrina was a disaster beyond the
average person's imagination
and very little of it survived on the
internet a lot of that [ __ ] got censored
bad bad [ __ ] happened during that
mad max stuff mass rapes mass murders
there's still tens of thousands of
people's missing never found there's no
telling what happened to them most of
them died in flooding but who knows
maybe they died before murders and rapes
um
[ __ ]
amazing amounts of theft
[ __ ]
just man it was like a genocide
and it was just a natural disaster that
[ __ ] hit
and then after that it was just the [ __ ]
it was like unleashing the [ __ ]
mongols
uh
[ __ ] organized crime started fighting
themselves fighting each other in the
streets
then they sent in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
named general honore who was a damn
he was a he was a national guard general
and they sent him in there to disarm the
population but really all he did was
disarm old ladies and then
mobs came in afterwards and [ __ ]
killed those old ladies and took all
their [ __ ] totally unconstitutional
um because it was just
they were taking away people's ability
to defend themselves
and so
strong young men ruled the [ __ ]
streets during that time
once those guns were gone they only got
some of them really
uh just [ __ ] it was a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and during that time because i lived
through that i lost all faith in [ __ ]
organized government
they're just totally incompetent
and they don't care about you
they only care about their
careers and how they look on tv they
give a [ __ ] about you
grandparents says uh they're talking
about water beds is there anything more
80s than a water bed water honestly i've
yeah i think that was more of a 70s
although i do remember like 80s uh
people in the 80s because i remember my
best friend had one and i thought that
was the coolest thing ever and this was
like
yeah mid 80s mid to late 80s i want to
say
and uh
i think i had one for a little while
but i don't know i couldn't get used to
it i'm just kind of like what
it's moving i just i want to be still
when i'm sleeping i don't like it and
somebody asked um don't they have to
change the water out of that stuff every
now and then no see that's what i always
wondered but you would think you put
bleach into water and then seal it yeah
see that's what they i thought they put
bleach
or something in it i i had two of them
uh when i was a kid grew up with them
because they were they were actually
cheap and in california water bed was
cheap cheap cheap cheap it was much
cheaper than a uh than a regular
mattress
and they were comfortable man and they
were and and you could set the
temperature on one so you get in to get
nice and [ __ ] warm and cozy
uh but no they didn't you put a little
bit of bleach in it and it never grew
anything oscar i didn't really witness
any atrocities during katrina i heard
about them from the from the police and
then saw videos afterwards and sometimes
deering and uh
oh no cops going rogue that's one of
them um
some of the guys from nopd were going
rogue running around stealing cars
raping women shooting people
um
then uh they had people in that damn
coliseum and [ __ ] bad [ __ ] happened
there in that stadium
then they tried to evacuate them on
buses and they had dudes on the [ __ ]
gangs on the buses [ __ ]
raping people's wives and [ __ ] on the
buses that was [ __ ] bad
um just no man uh
[ __ ] it's a
it's kind of a different situation
because some of the some of the worst
areas that were hit were in the low
lands that didn't really they weren't
real low
uh property value so it's low income
areas
it flooded pretty bad
if you know anything about african
americans that have like uh urban
backgrounds they can't swim so a lot of
them drowned
um
the
three or four of those [ __ ]
old folks homes
the staff ran and left all the people in
the old folks homes and they died
from drowning from [ __ ] uh
uh flooding
uh cops just [ __ ] said packed up and
they just [ __ ] took the cop cars and
[ __ ] ran with their families and [ __ ]
in some ways i didn't
blame them though because nopd at that
time was just falling apart
it was every man for themselves
there was no way to make to to [ __ ]
hold back a [ __ ]
mass of humanity it was panicking
so they just took the patrol cars went
home got their [ __ ] family packed up
some [ __ ] and [ __ ] went ran to texas
and [ __ ] abandoned the [ __ ]
vehicles there and started a new life
uh
but no i saw the videos
of the one of those old folks homes it
was just dead people in wheelchairs and
[ __ ] [ __ ] piled up in corners and
[ __ ] that in the in the uh it was bad
and they were already [ __ ] kind of
like half rotten
uh
abandoned the abandoned [ __ ] uh
orleans parish prison
yeah
and left dudes in the bottom floor to
[ __ ] basically drown in their cells
but there was about a foot above
some of them drowned because they
couldn't swim
and couldn't float but they did get most
of them out move them up to the second
floor
oh man it's just because the guards all
ran
it's just when i went
and it just looked like something out of
that middle east out of like a rock or a
[ __ ] country just
i've seen what it looks like when it
falls apart and it's [ __ ] savage
because
normal dudes start doing [ __ ] they
normally wouldn't do and then there's a
lot of people that normally should be in
prison but they're not and they get but
[ __ ] wild because there's nobody
there's no repercussions for what they
do and they don't think they're gonna
live long anyway so they just rob rape
steal murder
do whatever the [ __ ] they want to do in
their final days it's like somehow one
of them sci-fi movies
so uh
no
it was just his own thing
he read about what's been going on and
what had happened in like [ __ ]
croatia and [ __ ] bosnia and all that
it's nothing compared to that that was
its own thing there
but no man
collapsing civilizations is something
i've seen but i wasn't in it i was
in support and was shown videos and the
stories we'd have [ __ ] cops coming
back [ __ ] would be broke down
the females couldn't handle it cried
quit walk off a job
you know just
i don't blame them you know it's like
the route of civilization
danny rowling asked if people got
attacked by gators during katrina
uh i don't know well i'm sure they did
there wouldn't be reports of it because
that's what i mean it would just have
happened and nobody would but i'm sure
it happened there were whole
neighborhoods
evacuated just people gone no one ever
went back
they would go through there and search
those neighborhoods or be dead bodies in
some of those houses and they'd spray
paint on the outside of code it looks
like a square with an x in it and
numbers and it all meant about it was
checked there's two dead bodies in here
and it would be like the date that they
checked and it's yeah there's just whole
neighborhoods like that
and in those buildings and those
neighborhoods stood there for years
empty
they filmed some of the walking dead in
those
yeah with the series the walking dead
yep that's where it came that's what
they're filmed
well yeah i mean because you know why
pay for set dressing right when it's all
just right there i mean you know
sadly
uh
let's see do do do jenny looks like
morticia today thank you i'll take that
tell you those long
earlier like i put this on at like
i don't know like 11 a.m or something
like that because i had to record a
video earlier i was like oh i'll do the
wig today and then like i had it on and
i recorded the video and then like an
hour after that i'm like oh my god this
[ __ ] is giving me a headache so i had to
take it off for like three or four hours
before we did the show so i'm like oh my
god my head hurts
um let me see uh
where did it do
i saw something else that i wanted to
yeah some of the yeah tina some of the
waterbeds were waveless
they had
basically tubes of plastic to connect
the top to the bottom it was like an
empty tube that went through it there's
no way i could describe it
there was like a cell that went through
there so a wave really couldn't
move through it too much i didn't like
those though i liked the ones without
those they were a lot cheaper and i
liked the waves
but you see you like the waves i'm black
how much wave action you got by how much
water you put in it
yeah and the more full it was the less
waves you got i didn't mind them but i
kind of feel like water beds ironically
were better for me like if you weren't
sleeping in a bed with somebody else
when you were sleeping with somebody
else every time they rolled over it woke
me up because i'm like god damn it
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
uh cheryl is asking about my lipstick
always looks so good thank you it's not
always the same okay i'm gonna show you
what it is because some this is actually
a combo of like a really expensive one
that i'm actually running out of and i
can't afford to get another one um and a
really cheap one that i got at dollar
general so i'm to get them so i'll show
you so you talk about them for a second
during that katrina time man i
nowadays [ __ ] mres are worth so much
money
man
i was probably getting [ __ ] 12 or 13
of those [ __ ] mres a day
because they were issuing them to the
cops and they were issuing and issuing
them to cops patrol officers
faster than they could eat them
and [ __ ] i was [ __ ] doing things
on their cars and [ __ ]
you know in fact we were moving pallets
of supplies
and they would rotate their old [ __ ]
mre stock out and just leave it there
like it was garbage i was taking that
[ __ ] home
and eating it i was living off the i
love hours being next military i [ __ ]
love them you know but
go ahead what do you want to see
oh i was talking about this lipstick
this is
now this [ __ ] is like really expensive
and i will say that i think it's too
expensive it's good but it's too
expensive for what it is this is nars
nars
i can't remember the name of this color
i think it's called just press play or
something like that
i can't remember what it is but it's
like a really this is almost like dried
up this [ __ ] right here was 38 [ __ ]
dollars okay but i bought it a long time
ago it lasted a long time and it's
drying up but what i'm doing right now
is i'm mixing it with this [ __ ] right
here
which is just some [ __ ] that i picked up
at dollar general
right there and i don't even know what
[ __ ] color this is it was a buck
literally so i'm like mixing the two
together to like make it last longer and
i don't even know what [ __ ] color
this is it's called oh it's called
hollywood no it's called really red
that's the color and i got it at a
dollar general so i'm just mixing those
two up like i said nars i like these
they're like a lip stain more than a
lipstick because i don't like glossy
anything i like matte
um
and this stays on forever
um but 38
a little pricey for something that size
does last a while and it stays on good
but
i was like i'm not paying 38 again for
that i do like it but come on
so you know let's just just say
um let me see
nars is worth it jenny i mean it is
but
is it a dress it's not it's like a um
it's like it's a top and a skirt
i need another drink probably oh and you
see that yeah i'll get you one yeah
jenny i spend less than 15 on makeup a
year says dj maniac
i wish i could honestly i do try to like
keep [ __ ]
i have ipsy
which
uh is actually pretty good it's ten
dollars a month and they send you like a
little
bag every month of
five like sample things and you can pick
like a couple things that you want in
there so
i'll i usually get
you know you don't always pick what you
can get but a lot of times they'll send
you like primers which are nice um a lot
of times they'll send you like uh
eyeliner pencils or you know
the liquid eyeliner or they'll send you
like um
what do you call it uh mascara which is
good i don't think i've bought mascara
in like forever because i always get one
in my ipsy bag so that's really nice
but
i try to keep [ __ ]
honestly i found that makeup like not
super cheap [ __ ]
um
but just mid price drugstore stuff is
usually good enough
and even then i find that stuff is a
little bit too expensive thank you you
know what happened the other day
we got this box in the mail
and it was
not addressed to us it was addressed to
somebody that used to rent this house a
long time ago and we tried to like
figure out where they'd gone and stuff
like that and we couldn't figure that
out and i looked at it and i was like oh
this is one of those subscription box
things where they send you
like you know samples of cosmetics every
month or whatever and we couldn't find
out like where this person was so tom's
like well you might as well open it and
see what the [ __ ] is in there and there
was actually some really really nice
like very expensive
makeup in there and like a lot it wasn't
just like a sample size it was big so it
was like it was a primer
um
a regular foundation
and a concealer
and the foundation is a little
dark
but i mixed it with some [ __ ] i already
had and it worked out really nice so i
was like hey free [ __ ]
i like that
normally i get the stuff that's like um
i usually just get maybelline or
something like that which i think is
eight or nine bucks for the uh for the
foundation
and
i kind of like the covergirl
um
powders
but
there's another one that i get too but i
haven't remember i usually get the
covergirl ones but i usually order those
off amazon because if you go on amazon
if you go in a store those covergirl
powders i think are eight or nine bucks
each but if you go on amazon you can get
two of them for six dollars or 683 or
something like that and i just put that
on a pers on a uh what do you call it
like a so they send it every six weeks
so because i go through a lot of that
[ __ ]
so
uh but i like that i usually get creamy
natural or
whatever the lighter one
of that is because my skin's kind of
light
um whatever happened to the tv
commercial about activa what the
the pooping yogurt
the one with uh
jamie lee curtis
i don't remember that one
well it was a yogurt that had um
you know it's enzymes in it that were
supposed to make you poop they can't
they couldn't say that in the commercial
well i guess they could but what year
was that almost been in service or
something no it wasn't that one no it
wasn't that long ago
[Laughter]
cheryl says i've been using uh nyx
cosmetics nice deep right yeah i've got
those a couple times too
i like to like try out different things
because
i don't know i feel like sometimes i'll
go get like a nice red
and then i put it on i'm like it's not
red enough
i don't know
i don't know how it could be red or red
than it actually is but
i don't know
i do try to get like the reddest red
that they have
and honestly like to keep it on too i
like to have like a
lip liner pencil so i'll do like lip
liner pencil like all over and then
powder the lips and then put the
lipstick on too that usually makes it
last longer if i'm gonna be wearing the
makeup for a long time like if i'm going
out or something
um tila says i order my makeup online
now they have the drugstore makeup
locked up now here in california
yeah i get a lot of my stuff online to
be honest i get my stuff from ipsy or
you know powders and stuff like that i
usually just order from amazon and i
just have it on a subscription because
it's cheaper
and
i don't really have a lot of problem
with it i like all the free [ __ ] that i
get well it's not free it's ten dollars
a month but the stuff that i wouldn't
normally buy i especially like the
primers i don't usually buy any primer
but and i don't usually wear it every
day but when you're going out
you know and the makeup is going to be
you know i'm going to be dancing and
sweaty and stuff like that it actually
does help like keep the makeup from
melting off your face so that's actually
really helpful and it makes your [ __ ]
look all nice and poreless and
everything which is good
um
kanavatsan is talking about uh archive
81. i know i still have i think i still
have like um one or two episodes of that
that i have to finish and i still
haven't finished it yet but i will get
around to it
activia
yeah tila agrees nyx is the best
drugstore makeup brand i should probably
get more of that i need to try out some
of their foundations and stuff i do like
the foundation that i have
but
i like to try different kinds because
when i was growing up i was always broke
and i didn't really have money to
experiment with different kinds so
usually i would just get the same stuff
that my mom always had because a lot of
times i would just catch my mom's makeup
so i just got used to using that and she
always used like maybelline or covergirl
because she could get it at the grocery
store and it was cheap so
for a long time i just bought that
but
what i was gonna say senator says uh
he's he doesn't he doesn't agree with
amazon he says he wouldn't do a deal
business with him i got amazon plus i
mean they do suck but i mean as a
company they're they're sucky but oh man
that [ __ ]
i respect dude's game man [ __ ] uh
it's the first company like that
and when you're kind of a monopoly
you're kind of a threat you're kind of a
threat to mankind really because you can
abuse your power it's only a matter of
time before you got parallel systems
whereas two or three of those
that way they can't throw their weight
around
yeah i mean in a lot of ways i feel bad
using them but in some ways it's like in
on some things i can't help it because
it's like look i don't have a lot of
money and
it's honestly much cheaper and much
easier for me to just like have
subscriptions for [ __ ] that i'm gonna
buy all the time
like shampoo and coffee and things like
that that i need all the time and it's
like it seems much cheaper for me to
just order it from them and just have
them drop it off at my house every six
weeks or whatever it's a monopoly noah
there's no other oh yeah so i'm offering
that kind of service but then monopolies
don't last forever if you look at
history there'll be another one like
that
and when that happens they're not quite
as a threat to things because they get
involved in politics they throw their
[ __ ] money around they started trying
to game the system in their favor
but i will give amazon this
jim bezos
jeff bezos is a rich [ __ ] okay
he was born a nerd you look at that dude
you go god damn that's a beta that
[ __ ] beta is [ __ ] i saw him
recently he's on a yacht
he's laying there with a [ __ ] whole
harem of these fine [ __ ]
women probably in their 40s
and bezos stands up and the
[ __ ] looking good man you know
he's on hrt you know he's taking gear
but he looks like a man he looks like
[ __ ] vin diesel now
and i i looked at this situation i was
going you know what i respect him
because i understand what he's doing
he's one of the richest mens in the
world
usually those dudes
live a life of luxury on those [ __ ]
yachts
paying these hot girls to [ __ ] them
and they're ugly and disgusting looking
okay they're paying women to [ __ ] them
normally if he didn't have that money
they wouldn't be getting that [ __ ] okay
these women are gonna put up with this
[ __ ] okay
because of the money but in his case at
least he's like
well he's probably paying anyway at
least i'm not gonna put these women
through a hard time i'm gonna [ __ ]
look as good as i can for them because
some of those guys don't give a [ __ ]
they don't even give a [ __ ] well some of
the guys think feel like well they don't
have to they don't they have money so
powerful why should i make an effort you
have to make all exactly exactly so i'm
gonna give bezos that
he he he's a man he's got
some pride
you know what i mean
if he's
gonna be rich
he's gonna try to be as hot as he can
look and i'm gonna say bezos bet you
look a hot man he's 50 something years
old he's looking good he's looking real
good and he didn't he and he doesn't
have to a rich man doesn't normally have
to because
they usually take the easy way out and
just pay the girl oh no blow you know
weinstein type go ahead and blow me
[ __ ] you know what i mean i'm gonna
give you two million dollars of course
you're gonna blow me
you know
yeah i'm ugly but yeah you gotta do what
you gotta do you know what i mean
[ __ ] you torturing that girl make her
do that she doesn't want to do that
you know
she's not enjoying that
she's not into it so at least he's
trying to get the women into it
and i'm looking at who he's [ __ ]
hanging out with and they're of his
caliber he's of their caliber so no
my hat's off too most rich guys don't
even give a [ __ ] he gives a [ __ ]
is he a good dude probably not probably
not but he's i think he's better than
them well i mean to get that much money
you kind of have to be you gotta be bad
dude um
you know
but i was just gonna say like that just
goes to show don't pick on the nerds in
high school because yeah they're gonna
have millions of dollars not all of them
later on not all of them well no i'm
just saying that
uh jenny did you finish midnight mass
it's great i still haven't i really need
to get around to that i seriously i
think i watched like the first three or
four
episodes and then i got distracted and
you know like a squirrel or something
and i didn't uh get to do it tila says i
respect bezos's ex-wife
ching
uh tammy says amazon treats their
employees like crap but so does walmart
yeah good point there actually kind of
most companies treat their employees
like crap so tila goes i respect bazel's
ex-wife i just said that she posted all
the damn [ __ ] dollar signs and [ __ ] i
just said that i was reading it
[Laughter]
funny he keeps repeating the things i
said like
five seconds later
uh cheryl says we don't have target here
anymore huh
yeah we still got honestly target or
target
as we call it um
that's kind of like i don't know they
they might not treat their employees any
better but at least their [ __ ] is like
they seem to have like a slightly higher
class of stuff
than walmart walmart's kind of like the
but i don't even like to go to walmart
there's something really depressing
about walmart evidently you [ __ ]
work on the street
the the [ __ ]
the walmart
over there where in sanford where we
just lived we i used to go there for
good deals it was fine it was evidently
the one that's here is [ __ ] real
[ __ ] shady
real shady i gotta go check for myself i
remember the one that i that used to be
by my old apartment in i think winter
park yeah i was like i would go to that
because it was like the closest cheapest
thing like to buy groceries but i hated
going there every week it was like so
shifty
yeah and it's just
i understand why people shop there look
i don't [ __ ] on anybody for shopping
anywhere because like look you do what
you got to do okay but you know
everybody's broke we're all like just
[ __ ] struggling through this [ __ ] i'm
not gonna like judge you
but
walmart's
bummed me out
just go i don't know it's just like a
whole vibe man what the [ __ ] is the vibe
with that store that there some of them
are kind of grubby looking and worn out
you know well they're saving money by
not putting decor and they're just it's
just very functional
but walmart's where you go if you want
to get a case of damn spam or if you
want to get a whole bunch of [ __ ]
like
dried or your powdered milk you know
what i mean um it's where you know
people what are you talking about
powder milk is good for [ __ ] recipes
it's good for hurricanes
uh you're gonna get neato and that's
like down in the
in the uh in the hispanic section
um they got two different kinds of neato
they got regular neato and then they got
the neato that you can use for baby
formula
uh you know it's got all the stuff in
there for babies and [ __ ]
uh it's where you go if you want to get
like
big cases of ramen noodles
you know it's yeah like if you want
it like i said i think i said this on
the last show but for whatever reason
like the last couple weeks i've become
obsessed with the whole like sub genre
of youtube videos that are like extreme
grocery haul challenges where it's like
i ate for a week for ten dollars and i
made 21 meals
and like i'm fascinated by what they buy
and almost always not always but
sometimes they uh shop at walmart a lot
of times they do aldi though
although there's a there's a whole sub
sub genre of them that do entire grocery
hauls and 21 uh meals for the week at
dollar tree yeah so they'll buy 10 worth
of stuff at dollar tree and make 21
meals out of it and that [ __ ] is
impressive i'm impressed yeah i'm
impressed yeah i wouldn't buy fresh
vegetables there but it's but it's good
for like canned stuff canned stuff dried
beef yeah i mean because that's kind of
the same everywhere they can't [ __ ] it
up can't [ __ ] it up frozen chicken wing
or frozen chicken wings frozen chicken
patties if you if you're looking for
[ __ ] like that you know
i mean they're good for because they're
great value brand
usually cheaper not always but it is
usually cheaper than some of the other
things if you need like staples yeah
flour sugar spices rice like a bagel
yeah [ __ ] like that it's good for that
kind of stuff
um
fresh vegetables like we like other kind
of stuff i would guess yeah this
selection always looks like someplace
else so yeah fresh vegetables and meat
their selection always looks shitty
it's frozen stuff canned stuff big bulk
stuff
big old things of them damn [ __ ]
cereals those malto meal cereals i like
their copy of [ __ ] lucky charms they
got fake lucky charms some multi-meal
cereal get a big old thing of that i
don't even know if that still exists
[ __ ] germs
things of them i i like cereal uh
frosted flakes and you keep talking
about frosted mini wheats like like
you're like you've been thinking about
mini weeds
honestly frosted mini wheats is one of
my favorite cereals frosted minerals the
white ones are the brown ones
what do you mean
there's two different kinds there's like
white ones and there's brown ones right
no
i was thinking of chex i was thinking of
chex yeah the mini wheats they're all
kind of tan colored right and they're
cut they're frosted early on once yeah
they're frosted hence frosted many ways
i thought some of them were bran and
they're darker no no okay
i mean they have just like regular as
many wheats that aren't frosted that
don't have like the sugar frosting on
there but you kind of need that little
bit of sugar frosting on there because
by i mean they're okay by themselves but
they kind of need that little
thing of sugar
uh frosted mini wheats probably my
favorite cereal
my second favorite one i don't even know
if they make these anymore i like any
ones i like like uh honey bunches of
oats or ones that have like real thick
crunchy flakes and like chunks of like
nuts and granola and [ __ ] like that i
like crunchy ass cereal i don't like no
soggy ass cereal you know what i'm
saying captain crunch is good too tito's
ass about costco if we shop there i've
never been to a costco i don't think we
go to sam's we have a sam's membership
yeah um i don't there are costco's
around here but i can't think offhand
like where one is i know there's one
around here but i've never seen it sam's
is where you go for certain things man
the [ __ ] price yeah sam's is kind of
the same it's buying this bulk though
the big yeah yeah big stuff we do at
sam's run
once a month once a month once every
couple months once every six weeks
something like that
yeah and then that's where yes [ __ ] that
we use a lot of
coffee
eggs yeah um you know rice [ __ ] like
that
uh cheryl was saying that she spends a
thousand dollars a month in groceries
how do they do it like ten dollars a
week
um
it's a lot of rice and beans not gonna
lie yeah
uh for protein it's almost always eggs
and or chicken
um
no no no i'm i'm talking about like the
videos we're talking about uh so usually
you're gonna see them buy about the same
things because they're buying things
that
are filling that are you know fairly
nutritious and will go a long way and
that you could put in a lot of different
dishes yeah so you'll see a lot of them
buy
like a big thing of brown rice a big
thing of beans and or lentils uh you'll
see them buy like a whole chicken and
they'll use that for two or three
different dishes during the week
you'll see them buy like some other
starches like maybe a bag of potatoes or
maybe like a big thing of pasta or
something like that um and then
sometimes they'll get like some fresh
vegetables almost always they will get
at least one onion and at least one
garlic clove for flavor because you know
you're going to be eating a lot of they
eat a lot of mexican food too they'll
usually buy like a big thing of
tortillas because you can do a lot of
[ __ ] with that yeah
cheaply we do it yeah we do it too
um so
and they'll do a lot of casseroles they
do a lot of casseroles and a lot of soup
like a lot of homemade soup you would be
surprised what you could do with eggs oh
an oatmeal a lot of will buy a lot of oh
and a big thing of flour because with
flour you can make muffins you can make
bread you can make noodles
you can make all different things with
that
you'd be surprised what you could do
with eggs
there's a lot of nutrition in eggs and
it's very low cost a good example would
be like china
china has [ __ ] meat quality and the good
quality meat that they do have is very
expensive
so bodybuilders in china really can't
afford to [ __ ] get
protein
from meat
there it would cost them an arm and legs
they do with eggs those dudes will eat
nine eggs a day
in china
i love eggs to meet protein requirements
but they do the eggs in different ways
each time but it's a protein i mean you
can do a [ __ ] ton of different stuff
with it and when you look at what
they're paying
a week you know what i mean it's not
much so
eggs really do punch way above their
weight when you actually look at the
price yeah i mean they're very cheap and
they're very nutritious and you can do a
lot of different [ __ ] with them yeah and
if you focus on eggs instead of buying
them by the dozen you want to buy them
by the case
that's what i don't even think i paid 20
bucks for a case of eggs because i love
eggs i think it's like 17 bucks and
there's a [ __ ] ton of eggs
lots of them big box yeah it's a big box
big box i think it's like we and we
usually
but if i was gonna
if my only source of protein like if i
was in the chinese situation where meat
sucked
i'd buy two or three cases a week a
month and just you know
eat nine eggs a day
i can do that yeah
eat some for breakfast and then you do
them differently for lunch and then you
use them in other things like you know
you can take eggs and mix them with
[ __ ] oat with with with uh with
oatmeal and oats and then bake it in
something you know what i mean and make
like a like a meatloaf
you know you can mix it with flour and
make egg noodles yeah you can do all
kinds of stuff with it you could do all
kind of different stuff with it and
honestly like nowadays everybody makes
those egg bites which are super easy you
make them like in a muffin tin you just
put some fresh veggies some eggs and a
muffin tin you put them in the oven and
it makes like little yeah egg bites they
even sell them at dunkin donuts and
starbucks and they have a
[Music]
yeah you could do [ __ ] like that too you
could put them in ramen ramen we do that
all the time
uh
honestly we used to like heart yeah we
used to hard boil like you know a dozen
eggs at a time yeah then you'd have them
in the fridge you could either have them
for breakfast
you'd have a couple hard-boiled eggs and
a cup of coffee or red rice with a bunch
of eggs in it yeah
or or we would make ramen noodles and
throw a couple hard-boiled eggs in there
yeah and some you know veggies and [ __ ]
so you know uh tila says lately i've
been doing sourdough toast smear on
avocado and put an egg on top with hot
sauce see now that sounds delicious
and delicious and honestly that's
something that i've seen a lot on those
videos too is like a lot of them will do
like toast with they'll buy like one
avocado for the week and then they'll
cut it up in little pieces so they can
like use it all week long
like smear it on toast and then like put
an egg on top
oh yeah
lu hernandez says a couple of cans of
tomato sauce
some packages of pasta rice beans and
tortillas you can feed a lot of people
and honestly that's how us mexicans
survive a lot of the videos are that
it's like you get they'll get like a can
of you know tomato sauce or diced
tomatoes
uh you know some a big thing of
tortillas
some rice and beans yeah and honestly
most of the meals they make are mexican
yeah are mexicans the thing is those
look i gotta say something fernandez
you look at the physique of a mexican
you can see there's too much damn too
much damn carbohydrates little mexican
guys even the ones in the cartels man
the little short dudes [ __ ] pot belly
that's cause they're eating like that
not enough protein
they're eating all that damn
carbohydrate just turns into sugar
it's calories but it's not nutrition
you all need to stop them damn
carbohydrates and so it's a planet with
something with protein whey protein you
know like the [ __ ] weight shakes
protein that helps a lot the problem is
that the prices haven't gone down on
that it's still like 30 bucks for five
pounds
[ __ ] whey protein
um
and eggs
if you were to take a mexican diet i do
cook a lot of mexican
we do we do a lot we eat a lot of
mexican food but um and it is good but i
try to really make it a lot heavier in
protein
than carbohydrates less tortillas less
rice less beans more meat more
vegetables
and
you won't get that
dad bod we call that dad bod here short
[ __ ] dumpy
cheryl says i go through 24 eggs every
two weeks but the dog eats them too yeah
honestly when i lived alone
uh and i was usually broken didn't have
a [ __ ] ton of money to spend on
groceries
eggs were my go-to man honestly
i would just i would eat fried eggs for
dinner or boiled eggs for dinner lots of
times
i mean they're easy they're very filling
i would need two and i'm like okay i'm
full
you know they're good for you so
that's that was my whole thing
uh way too much carbs tommy you're right
about that for sure way too much carbs
yeah and i you know i get that you have
to kind of balance
um
you know art it's better to have any
food at all than like like calories if
you're starving obviously i grew up my
teens in brazil
brazil was the same way
in brazil carbs were [ __ ] cheap
you know pasta rice potatoes
beans they still aren't and bread so
they ate lots of it they they
compensated
for quality with quantity and it did
taste good what they made tasted great
but it's not it put a lot of fat on you
uh but with brazilians ate a lot of that
[ __ ]
but what i noticed in sao paulo they
tended not to get that fat
and it's because they [ __ ]
drank pinga with kasasa or it was like
moonshine and they [ __ ] danced
constantly they were dancing
[ __ ] they were very physical
a lot of hard physical labor
but you could tell that a lot of
brazilians were protein starved
it's just not enough protein in that
diet
you know
you can't live off of that forever and
maintain a good physique although i'm
going back i'm looking back at my brain
during that time
the people i'm talking about were mostly
in their 20s and 30s so really age
hadn't caught up with them yet yeah it
might have been that because honestly
when you're still in your 20s you can
get away with eating a bunch of [ __ ]
right without right
the older people were did have dad bod
once you hit 30 35 you can't take that
can't get away with uh [ __ ] you used to
be able to get like this anymore so you
gotta really watch carbohydrates
yeah
because honestly [ __ ] man
yeah i knew yeah growing up with uh but
especially dudes i kind of feel like
dudes have it a little bit easier
because they seem to like burn fat much
too
yeah
so dudes could like eat
man i i've seen dudes like in their 20s
they would like go out drinking beers
and beers and beers they would inhale a
whole entire pizza they'd wake up the
next day they eat like a big giant
[ __ ] burrito and they were like
skinny yeah and i'm like how is this
possible
dude man yeah
i eat one bite of a cupcake and gain a
pound khan's in there saying i'm gonna
send you this mole video yeah there's
this uh
there's this
really good
youtuber that uh khan sent me a link to
her name is cookie the name of the
channel is cooking concluding
cooking concluding and
claudia you know
and she's a little mexican girl and she
teaches you how to cook these dishes
and it's a good channel
and she can make something out of
nothing
um
i'm going to plug that challenge cooking
claudia
it's a good channel
but like i told you [ __ ] khan you all
eating too much goddamn carbohydrates
and you [ __ ] fry everything in them
down [ __ ] oils and pig fat
i don't understand how y'all [ __ ] i
don't know if that got that damn aztec
genetics or something i don't know why
y'all don't have [ __ ] quadruple
bypasses by 50.
eating all that damn pork grease a white
person couldn't eat that and get away
with it well it must be genetic i
certainly could not it must be genetics
i don't understand how y'all living as
long as you can eat not eating all that
seriously i kind of like look dj maniac
says i'm in my 40s and i can still do
that i can't gain weight i've tried you
shut up right now yeah
i wish that i had that those [ __ ]
genetics i wish
don't get me wrong
i have to if i was loved poor greece my
dad nearly died for i love that [ __ ]
but honestly it just [ __ ] us up man i
can't honestly if i want to lose weight
like when you remember like a few years
ago when i lost like 80 90 pounds yeah i
had to literally eat i had to eat under
a thousand calories a day which is
not a lot uh in case every time
seriously every
coffee i didn't hide no creamer no sugar
i just drank coffee black um i just
everything was
the lowest possible calorie and then it
was hard and i still had to like [ __ ]
do bike every day i had to like [ __ ]
run every day i had to do this and that
and it was really really difficult
and my body just does not want to let go
of weight i have to eat practically
nothing to lose weight practically
nothing i have to eat under a thousand
calories a day
and which is
not ideal and honestly like most
nutritionists well that's like not
enough calories to sustain blah blah i'm
just like look
i'm either gonna eat under a thousand
calories and be thin or i'm gonna eat
over a thousand calories and be fat just
that's just the way my body worked sorry
but that's just the way it is uh gilded
h phoenix says sitting here looking at
that nosferatu poster in the background
i think something has to be said tom
could totally pull off nosferatu at
halloween time
the profiles match up perfectly
oh and you know what
now that i'm looking at that
that's my favorite poster by the way i
love that i got that in britain like
many many years ago i think my
ex-mother-in-law bought me that for my
birthday
like
20 years ago or something
um
tom has a jacket very very similar to
that
yeah and he's bald all he needs is like
some pointy ass ears
yeah
i can see it
we're already thinking about halloween
because i'm like
halloween always sneaks up on me so i'm
always kind of like uh
i think i said this on last week's show
it was kind of like man i'm already
thinking about what should i do for
halloween this year because i don't want
to sneak up on me i want to like buy a
little bit at a time so i'm not
you know pressed for cash when the time
comes
uh tila says oh wait where'd it go i
lost it
tila says my boy cousins in high school
oh my god they eat their asses off
thanksgiving they have three or four
full plates see honestly
i wish i could eat like that i really do
honestly even when i was young i
couldn't eat like that
this every year at thanksgiving we have
all we have so much food you guys and
it's just and i look forward to it all
you just i'm like oh boy oh boy like a
big turkey and like all the potatoes and
stuffing and all this pumpkin pie and
all that i eat one plate and then i'm
like
and now i'm gonna puke
i don't understand
i try to eat a little bit more i'm like
nope gonna throw up
so i don't understand how people can eat
like three or four i don't even
understand how you when we go to the
chinese buffet
i don't understand how you can eat more
than
two plates of stuff
because i eat one plate of stuff and i'm
like i'm probably pretty okay i'm going
to go back and try out a couple little
things that i didn't and then i'm like
oh oh no are they seeing that look like
a red [ __ ] klaus [ __ ] cansky i
don't know they said you yeah you need
to be nosferatu like from they see the
poster
because you have a coat kind of like
that yeah that would be a good halloween
costume
yeah yeah you have a coat like that
[Laughter]
see you can do it
you could do it
oh he just he couldn't resist he was
just he couldn't resist it
goodness tom
wow
you're so vain
you probably think this podcast is about
you
[Laughter]
my mom had that album yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god we're so funny
i haven't done i haven't done [ __ ]
like goth makeup in a long time
yeah was the last i think i re the last
time i remember you doing it was vampire
ball which was a few years back a few
years back in tampa
that was fun but holy crap that vampire
ball in tampa
it's at the castle yeah
40 million people came to that i don't
know i mean it felt like
it's that crowded actually
well you can't really like move around
you can't even like get a drink at the
bar you have to stand there for like
half an hour because there's
oh pokey
hey say hi to everybody
do you know what pookie has been doing
all day today
she has been jumping up like mommy was
over there at her desk
and i'm over there working she has
decided
she jumps up on my desk and starts
licking my keyboard
i'm not entirely sure if
there's something on the keyboard that's
delicious to her
sweat
baby
so it's like now i have to wash my
keyboard every day because she's
probably like jumping up and like
licking it all night
she was like really getting into it too
she like sat down and everything
she like sat down she's like okay i
gotta i gotta like spend some time on
this then she's like licking all the
buttons and i'm just like oh my god
jesus christ i was trying to like read a
book like on my ebook thing and
i was just kind of like i couldn't do it
because she kept licking and it kept
like skipping pages so
this is what having a cat is like
all right let's see around mango
uh john goris said was that carol king
the song no uh you're so vain was uh
carly simon
that was carly simon
carol king was uh
sh man she did all those songs from
uh
that [ __ ]
pookie's watching alligators everywhere
on she's watching youtube she's green
yeah she's like she's like why wait
mommy's there she's like little
rubbing on your hand and then mommy's
there and she's big i don't understand
how this happens
this also you know what she did last
night i think it was five in the morning
and i mean i'm kind of used it doesn't
even really wake me up fully anymore
because i'm so used to her little pause
like hey i'm walking up your body like
boop boop and like her little legs come
up
and she came up
i was laying on my side and i had kind
of a blanket sort of halfway over my
head like that
and she comes up and she's like gonna
make biscuits on your head okay and she
just goes
yeah it's like five in the morning
and i just like
i mean you can't help but laugh it's
like it's absurd
because
you know
she does it like it's her job
all right so is there any other
questions you guys have any uh
questions about any other cases in the
back in in the past that we've done oh
look at pokey she's playing with the
mice
she's got her toy mice yeah kick it kick
it kick it get it get it get it
oh my goodness she's throwing it around
she's [ __ ] hilarious she's like i'm
pretending it's alive yeah
she throws it and then chases it
tila says can you imagine pookie with a
diamond collar so cool she did not like
the we got her some little reflective
collars when she used to go outside
which she does not anymore now that
we're at our new house because
i don't really like the idea for going
outside here it's just it's too open and
there's too many animals
it's too rural
uh so we don't let her out anymore
but when she used to go outside at our
old house which was safer she did have a
little pink collar with reflective stuff
on it and it was so funny because the
first time we put that on her she was
just like not having it she was like
ducking down trying to like escape
she got used to it after
i mean she got to a point we actually
trained her where if she wanted to go
outside she understood that she had to
have the collar on she didn't have it on
all the time we didn't put it on her
inside the house
but she understood that if she wanted to
go outside she had to have the collar on
so if she wanted to go out she would
like wait there with a little neck
extended
so we would put the collar on and she'd
be like okay thank you
but
i don't know it's like i always every
time like a holiday rolls around like
halloween or something months like
i get those little emails from chewie
with all the
little cat and dog costumes
and i always look at them i'm like
i'm like i should get i should give
pookie a little halloween costume or she
wouldn't wear it though
she wouldn't wear it i was gonna get her
a little sweater they had a little
sweater and it was only like six or
seven dollars with like it was a little
black sweater with like little skulls on
it
and i was like oh
cheryl the ice maker that we got
we got it from sam's
but i think it's on
i think it's on amazon also
it's frigidaire
they're about 90 to 95 delivered
they're worth it they come in a box
about that big it's handy that's the one
very handy it's working good
i mean like i said it's handy because we
have an ice maker downstairs but we're
lazy so we don't want to like walk all
the way downstairs it's not big it's
nice to have one up here
when you turn it off all the ice melts
and all the water goes down to the
reservoir again it's all recycled
yeah
it's good for the two of us just you
know two of us making drinks over the
course of the show it can easily keep up
with two people making drinks that size
yeah yeah
and and sometimes after we've done the
show like i'll get up the next morning
and there'll still be ice in there yeah
that i can use for ice water in the
morning
uh can you guys do cases about old cases
what does that mean really old cases
really old case oh yeah we do that yeah
we've done that
i i don't have any time limit
honestly i'm kind of a big fan well i
don't know if that's the right thing to
say but i'm i'm kind of really into
i'm for whatever reason i'm really into
like old like
old like late 19th century early 20th
century crimes maybe because i know that
they'll never be solved so it'll always
be like a mystery so i'm always like
fascinated by those
asking we're going to do a wrath of con
review
if i don't yeah we haven't done one of
those have we if i do wrath of
commentary we'll do the entire star trek
movie series because you have all of
them i have them all so we'll do with
motion picture rather con and then all
the ones maybe
after that we can do because um
those movies ranged from excellent to
okay
uh because we watched all of them
recently like within the past couple of
years yeah we watched all of them
because we have them all some were kind
of corny but they were all okay that's
okay though yeah honestly
more kirk spock and bones yeah i'm a fan
even if they're being silly and goofy i
don't i don't i don't mind it
uh the black dahlia we already did a
show about that
the blue dahlia was the movie that's
what she was named after
uh y'all they're remaking the exorcist
bad idea
i heard um
[ __ ] man what was it i heard they were
just today i heard they were remaking
something else but i wasn't mad about it
because i thought oh well okay but now i
can't remember what it is
why do they have to remake well honestly
they already did like a couple of
prequels right
recently fairly recently
that i heard weren't bad actually but
hey
gilded h phoenix says i like 18th and
19th century peddler transient murders
yeah see i'm it i don't know why but
the more recent uh a crime gets
the less interesting it is to me now t
said they're remaking salem's lot
oh no i did hear about that well i don't
know if that's it that
that doesn't necessarily mean it's a
remake it might just be another
adaptation of the novel there was
another remake of salem's lot i think
also made for tv uh that was kind of
flopped but they seemed kind of closer
to the book
um
that made for tv salem is a lot i have
it on [ __ ] dvd it's an excellent c
it's an excellent made for tv i love
that i still love that um a lot of it is
the way that mr barlow the way he looked
it was spooky well he was based on
nosferatu yeah
he looked like a
monster
i don't know it all depends on how they
remake it i would say yeah
remake it but remake it well
i can see another adaptation of salem's
lot i'm not i'm not mad about that
because like i said it was a novel first
and if you want to do another adaptation
of it because you know the original was
made for tv and that was a long time ago
it was like late 70s some people were
pissed off with dr sleep we saw dr sleep
in the theater i liked it
i liked dr sleep as well got the uh i
honestly and this may be a controversial
statement
i liked the movie better than the book
then we you didn't read the book did you
no i did we got the director's cut
blu-ray and it's [ __ ] great
the director's cut blu-ray of dr sleep's
[ __ ] better than better than the
movie i liked it
yeah
the thing is though there's so many
stephen king
[ __ ] him has like written so much stuff
and so much good stuff
that has never been adapted to film i
mean
i don't know maybe like some other
writers should be given a chance because
to be fair a lot of stephen king's stuff
has been adapted to film just because
he's written so much and honestly he so
much of his [ __ ] has been adapted to
film
that some of his like short stories or
other novels that i didn't know about
got adapted to movies and i didn't even
know about it yeah so
um
but you know
if you're gonna do
i i kind of feel like if you're gonna do
a movie of a stephen king thing
do a movie that hasn't been done before
yeah although i'm not bothered about
salem's lot being redone
although another thing too is i'm not a
big fan of vampire [ __ ] because i feel
like what else can you do with that
t i don't think they'll remake salem uh
phantasm
it's more likely that they'll add
a sixth movie to the series
because that that movie's kind of owned
privately owned by a dude who owns that
property and that that's his baby
if you ask me and i've said this before
you know on other shows
when it comes to a horror series
phantasm was the best one
it was the longest one and it had it was
the most consistently entertaining had
the most continuity
it had the most originality it was
building its own lore
it's its own thing
each in each one of those movies built
upon itself
that could only be be done by
basically a single man with a single
vision and this is his baby and this is
you know i mean and it's just and it's
weird as [ __ ] and he's like unapologetic
about it which is rad it's not something
you want to give to a hollywood studio
they will [ __ ] that up
i think number two was done by a
hollywood studio but they actually did a
good job with it wouldn't it i actually
yeah honestly phantasm 2 i would argue
is actually yeah that's the way
hollywood should be approaching horror
franchises because they actually did
that right he did that right
but five i [ __ ] loved them all all
the way up to five yeah they were all
good each each one was actually kind of
better
than the one before and the continuity
the world building
can we just say that i mean reg reg
reggie bannister and how sexy reg is how
those women love that he carries his
head
and [ __ ] reg the dick slinger he's so
awesome [ __ ] it's just that character
is just he's such a great character
he's such a great character yeah they
were absolutely
uh absolutely correct to like carry him
on through the whole thing and make it
like a road movie yeah and it just got
weirder and weirder and it's like i love
it i love that it's so common for dudes
like reg to get so much action from
those 22 23 year old women that look
like that i mean it's just you know i
mean
i kind of was not impressed because i'm
like oh that happens all the time with
dudes that look like that why are they
making this a big deal
[Laughter]
well it does though i mean that [ __ ] is
awesome wrench could pull
reg was pulling i don't know how he was
pulling but he was pulling because he's
funny and cool
how many times do i have to tell you
on this show he was ready it doesn't
matter if you're old and bald and [ __ ]
like that are you funny are you cool
are you are you good at [ __ ] it was a
great series
it was a great series uh you could pull
and i think it doesn't get the [ __ ]
recognition that it should i mean evil
dead got a lot of recognition and and
ash i do i do love you that is a really
good series too
but
man when it came to originality
and just something made up by just one
dude basically i will say like
evil dead consistently because they had
what three movies and then they had uh
the series and the series if you haven't
seen the series the series is great it's
so good the series is better than the
movie it's so good i love the series so
much i just where's the new series
when's the news
what'd they do like two or three seasons
of that oh my god it was just
lee majors was in the series
come on it was ashley's dad was lee
majors
honestly
the whole the scene with ash getting
stuck in the butthole of a
corpse made the whole series where i'm
like this is the best thing i have ever
seen
in the history of mankind we would
[ __ ] teach about rich
what did he say about reg where where
[Music]
yeah
he's the star after the tall man oh yeah
yeah how can you [ __ ] love red red is
[ __ ] awesome it just happened
i would hit that
i did that he's like he's [ __ ]
hilarious
uh john goris brings up bubba hotep uh
bubba was great yeah we've reviewed that
honestly seriously i love
love bubba hotep i've seen it a million
times
cab guy brings up the reanimator yeah
reanimator series was
right there with phantasm yeah most of
those were actually good i kind of feel
like just the first one uh gets all the
love you know understandably because the
first one was awesome
but the other ones in the series are
totally worth watching too yeah phantasm
evil dead and reanimator they're all
right there you know that's that's that
those are the greats
well the thing about the phantasm series
that we talk about a lot is i kind of in
my opinion at least
it was one of those ones that it was
made with love
yeah well one it was a completely
original vision it's totally weird it's
totally unapologetic about being it's
just building its own lore and i love
that
but
i really like that each movie gave you
something different and each movie was
totally worth watching like it didn't
lose quality at any point
um evil dead did that too but i kind of
feel like well they only had three
movies but then it went to series that
was like a lot later
so that's a little bit of a different
situation
you know it's not like i'm kind of
comparing it against your bigger ticket
horror franchises like friday the 13th
and you know nightmare on elm street
stuff like that which
you know let's be honest really like
declined in quality as the time went on
and i'm not saying that there weren't
like
i've look i've seen all of the friday
the 13th movies i've seen all of the
nightmare and upstream movies
multiple times so
um
but you know i don't think anyone's
going to argue that some of them are
like uh quality-wise like better than
others
obviously what have you got
oh there we go i got my health wafers
you got your health wafers yes
these are some of the cookies that he
bought at dollars i got these guys
when did i talk about this he went to
dollar general without telling me
it's only like it's down the street i
could literally walk
i could literally walk to dollar general
it's like it's right there it's right
outside the housing complex
and uh he went there without saying
anything right
like ten well no i'm just saying that i
don't i don't say you need my permission
i'm just saying i didn't even know you
went because if you if i'd known you
were going i said hey you bring me back
like some you know coffee drinks or
something oh yeah but you didn't ask me
i forgot
that's what i'm saying i wasn't going
there though i was going to publix to
get yeah for something else you know i
said i'm going to say that he's talked
to dollar general in public
15
worth of cookies 60 16 for the cookies
and the cookie package the whole package
of cookies and we're talking like a big
package like that or like a dollar each
yeah so in the fridge in there it's all
sodas which i don't drink
and cookies cookies that's all that's in
there
and this is why and you know cookies and
yet earlier you were berating people for
eating too many carbs and yet you were
stuffing people you're seven years i'm
not normal though
oh so you're allowed to have cookies but
no one else is i'm on so much junk
[Laughter]
i can eat anything
i have the metabolism of four or fifteen
year olds
okay yeah i'm on so much people you're
just eating you keep telling yourself
that
i don't well
i'm not tempted by the oh honestly that
worked out honestly the the nice thing
about you buying cookies and candy and
stuff is that usually you buy stuff that
i don't really like
so
what do you guys think i want to do no i
don't know i don't like it boogie wants
to try you want to try a waiver boogie
don't give her those i gave her
something she loved them oh she did it
she was like
she's not remember i remember i remember
the pink wave first she was like she did
actually eat a piece of paper
she doesn't usually eat people food the
only people food i've seen her eat is
well tuna fish obviously
she likes whipped cream yeah if you have
like ice cream or like a sundae or
something like that whipped cream on it
she's very into the whipped cream she'll
stick her face in the bowl she's like um
i'm not i'm not you don't want to eat it
if you don't eat it well she was going
to push it off the table yeah
what happened
she was like looking at she was going
like that and then tom took it away and
she was like what the [ __ ] i gave her
another one i was gonna push that off
the table
earlier today you didn't see but you
know why i have three pens there because
she steals them
she picked one pen up in my in her mouth
earlier see well you [ __ ] it up she
pushed her she's going down
[Laughter]
she pushed it off the table
has anybody figured out
why cats push everything off tables
listen
is she well no she's not she's licking
it and she crunched it and then spit it
back out she ate it last time
it's strawberry flavored
gee
okay she's kind of she's kind of licking
it
eat your wafer is that good for her i
don't really know if she should be
eating yeah
it's just sugar
at least it's not it's not chocolate so
no
because i know cats and dogs aren't
supposed to eat chocolate
it's like a it's like a strawberry wafer
strawberry tom don't care i'll give him
anything
she's just kind of like i don't i don't
know how i feel about shortening sugar
and [ __ ]
a little bit i thought that was funny
though how she like was very insistent
about pushing it off the desk before she
ate it
yeah she's like this can't be here this
isn't the way she's like
are you done you're not done you're not
done she's like no i think i am though
well she has a ritual too like every
single night
you know she we give her like regular
food and like her little temptations and
stuff
but i bought her in bulk like those
sheba meat sticks she loves those
but we only give them to her like
periodically because we don't always
have them
and tom keeps them in the drawer
on in the night stand like next to the
bed
and she knows that they're in there so
every single night like right around the
same time like right around 7 p.m when
we're kind of like relaxing in bed like
watching a movie or something she comes
in the room
with her little short legs and goes up
to the drawer and tries to like open the
drawer or tries to like jump up on the
thing it's like hey hey and then she'll
like sit there and like look at tom like
that like expectantly
like where where's my meat stick but
what she talking about where her husband
does the same thing by buying things you
don't like
read it out so that people can see it
uh you buy something i don't like jen he
does that on purpose yeah i know uh hubs
does the same thing oh i didn't know you
didn't like these [ __ ]
no i buy them i don't care if you don't
like him i buy well yeah that's what i
mean
he doesn't care if i like him or not
and like i said he he was going to
dollar general and i would have said hey
why don't you bring me like some dunkin
donuts like uh you know coffee drinks or
some starbucks coffee or whatever the
[ __ ] they got she's right she's
rewriting history i'm not re-white you
didn't even ask me
no you were working
i know but i was going to go to the
publix
and get soda no get booze oh so
yeah the liquor store yeah and all the
way back
i saw a dollar general says i'm gonna
get some cookies cookies
yeah i wasn't thinking about [ __ ]
cooking coffee drinks i was just
steaming he wasn't thinking about jenny
no
no of course not
imagine that
thinking about it i forgot about coffee
being conscientious i forgot about
coffee drinks
see how it goes see how it goes t i'm
supposed to i'm supposed to i'm supposed
to know what she's thinking about you
might have been thinking about buying an
ashtray or thinking about buying a
[ __ ]
basket why would i be thinking why would
i think of a [ __ ] coffee drink
because i've asked you to buy those for
me like more than once like when you've
gone to dollar general
i was like hey see what if they have
those
see if they have those dunkin donuts
like girl scout cookie flavored coffee
drinks if they have those for you so
when i go to so what you're telling me
is when i go to dollar terrible store i
come back with a with it with a coffee
drink ready to try to say
off the top
coffee drink
it's on lock right
whatever you tell me wait what
you're what you're trying to tell me is
that if i go to [ __ ] dollars general
store i better come back with a coffee
drink i didn't think you better come
back with that i just
all i said
oh it's gotta be my idea
no it was my no
all i said was it would have been nice
if you'd have asked me i didn't know
where i was going and i might have said
oh hey why don't you check and see if
they have summoners woman logic woman
logic khan khan you see how it is
kanavasana knows understanding he
understands totally his wife's the same
way hold on let me go put this up
he does the same way
i can't be a mind reader hold on
dude like dudes are a mystery to me
honestly when i go somewhere like when i
go to a store or something i usually ask
him if he wants something
or when i'm there i'm like oh tom might
like that so i'll pick it up
it's not weird i don't understand why
that's like weird or that's like out of
the i don't know
the way the way dudes brains work is is
mystifying to me i i have no i have no
idea i might not have even said that
like he might have just come in and said
hey i'm going to dollar general or you
want anything and i would have said
better like ah no i don't need anything
but
had he asked me i might have said oh hey
because he did he has asked me before
hey i'm going to dollar general
you know to get xyz he had to get a new
toilet seat or something and i was just
kind of like oh yeah bring me some if
they have some of those like cheap ass
cause dunkin donuts i don't know if
you're gonna but they have those like uh
bottled coffee drinks and they're
flavored like girl scout cookie flavors
they have a thin mint one which
isn't as good as you might imagine i was
a little disappointed but the
samoas one i think it's samoas
is actually pretty good although i will
say that i only i can only drink like
half of it at the same time because it's
a little much it's it's very very sweet
um but that's good it lasts longer
but you know
i'm just saying that
i might not have asked him to get
anything it just would have been i
didn't even know he went he came back
and he's just kind of like
he comes back in my car by the way he
doesn't have a car he's just a
motorcycle he's still going off no i
just said
he comes back in my car and he like
yells at me
who
you did you were like you know you
yelled like hey come get me help me get
all this stuff upstairs and i was just
like what stuff
where'd you go all right
and then like i had to carry like all
these big cases of like so i'm like
where did you go what happened where did
you watch if i go to daughter general
straw i'll bring you coffee drink thank
you okay that's all it sounds i didn't
know but okay i'll bring your coffee
drink but look
let me explain something to these people
uh oh he's tight he's tall i'm getting
ready to explain
at dollar general store it is not the
dollar store there's a difference
between yeah everything's not a dollar
yeah he's not a dollar don't think that
at the dollar store now at dollar tree
everything's a dollar yeah i think
dollar general store was made by dude
his last name was dollar
okay so he has like a loophole they put
little general stores in
this used to be a pretty rural area
wherever there was like
a place where they didn't have a grocery
store they put the general store there
and you'd be surprised what was in those
little things they'd be all kind of i
was actually the first time we went in
there because like i said the dollar
general we have a publix and a chinese
restaurant and chitlin liquor store and
[ __ ] like that like within a mile like
not even a mile i don't think but the
dollars go this is the [ __ ] boom dog
the dollar general is literally i could
walk to it yeah it's like right outside
of our housing complex right they got
almost a little bit of everything in
there and the first time i went in there
it's very very small
but the first time i went in there i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] they have
everything in here yeah like and i'm not
even talking about like food and like
all that kind of stuff they have
waste baskets toilet seats toys yeah
they got all kinds of weird [ __ ] like
that they have like makeup makeup they
have well they have like a whole section
they have rugs jeans they have like
furniture yeah yeah i was just like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i could furnish your whole
house in here right
so anyway for super cheap i was the guy
was flabbergasted they got their own
store brand called clover valley don't
get the [ __ ] orange juice it tastes
like [ __ ]
but they have um a section over cookies
most of the packages of cookies are a
dollar the most expensive is 1.50 that's
like the [ __ ] macaroon type
macadamia anyway
the cookie packages are that big they're
the size of a [ __ ] big old pack of
oreos they're a dollar
and the cookies are not bad yeah they
taste just like those mcdonald's land
cookies remember the the mcdonald's the
lemon sandwich cookies are actually
quite simple they've got sandwiches and
then they're like a mcdonald's cookie
with froth but they're the size and
shape of an oreo and in the middle of
them you either get vanilla frosting or
lemon frosting vanilla is pretty good
too the vanilla is a very good too then
they got a chocolate one that's just
like an oreo
i'm not super into oreos i got something
in there too if i'm gonna eat an oreo
it's gonna be a double stuff and then
they got a [ __ ] peanut butter version
that's like a nutter butter
the peanut butter ones they're like a
dollar we're all right you can get fat
on them things over there but i like the
lemon ones
lemon ones are the best ones although
the vanilla ones are pretty good too
yeah gotta say yeah so willie like a
handful of those like while we're
watching a movie but
i mean for a buck you can't really go
wrong and then i what i was looking for
was what what they call sun i was
looking for sunshine lemon coolers i
thought those would be oh i remember
those i can't find them they didn't have
a public so you guys know what those are
do they even make those anymore yeah i'm
pretty sure they do okay
i don't know if sunshine still exists
there was an older company
it was a round cookie
a flat round flat cookie that was kind
of like just a regular white cookie
and it had
instead of
instead of [ __ ]
chocolate chips in there had lemon chips
and then it was covered in powdered
sugar it's called a lemon cooler man
these things are [ __ ] good see man
lemon flavored anything
i'm on board with that we were like 13
12 13 14
[ __ ] summertime in the south eating
those things by the box getting [ __ ]
fat
those [ __ ] got you through puberty
those things man remember remember them
[ __ ] things yeah you and they were
cheap
you get a whole box of them tila says
how many bags of cookies did tom get at
the ghetto dollar store like 12. i think
it was 12 bags like 12 keys well i
didn't know like i have a more like more
like eight of them the rest of the [ __ ]
for a dollar i got is i got the [ __ ]
dollar gummy bears oh that's right he
got some
lemon heads lemon heads i don't like
dollar chocolate bars they had [ __ ]
okay now those were good they were good
they were caramel salt
yes the sea salt sea salt salt and
chocolate bars but those were decent
yeah and it's their brand they're good
yeah
but
out of the cookies i think i got about
eight big old eight big old packs of
cookies i mean they're still a tough we
haven't eaten a bunch of them yeah
they're still a [ __ ] done every time i
open the
the mini fridge to get ice i'm just like
man two of them cookies look at all
those cookies
through those [ __ ] packs or
packs of wafers the packs the wafers
that big and that thick
i can't eat them all in one setting for
a dollar eat about one third of them at
a time oh you could if you really tried
i'm sure yeah i don't know
think about it though like i said three
flavors chocolate vanilla strawberry and
see
what we've talked about before like tom
is more into like fruity fruity [ __ ]
yeah and i'm more into like chocolate
and nuts and stuff like that not always
it depends on what it is you didn't see
those other cookies i got in here though
what chocolate covered girl scout
cookies from clover valley oh okay yeah
the girl scout cookie you know the
chocolate minty chocolate oh the thin
mint the thin mint but covered in
chocolate oh okay like a girl scout
cookie but they're square
oh like the uh like grasshoppers like
grasshoppers yeah oh okay yeah yeah
those are good
you should put those in the freezer
those they are in the freezer another
refrigerator put them in there those are
i got those for like a dollar thirty
those are way a little bit more frozen
yeah
if you yeah if you like thin mints like
the girl scout cookies get uh get
keebler grasshoppers because they're
pretty much the same thing but freeze
them they're much better but the thing
about it though is that
i'm kind of like look
i'm the kind of i'm the type of person
that'll get fat if they just like sniff
a cupcake so if i'm gonna have
a cookie or if i'm gonna have a dessert
i want it to be something that i really
really like
you know what i mean i'm not gonna like
waste a bunch of
empty calories on something i don't
really enjoy so i don't really like
because like like i said a lot of times
when we go to the movies like he'll go
to cvs and like buy candy and he'll get
like gummy bears and stuff and he's
always like trying to give me gum it's
like look i don't want any [ __ ] gummy
bears okay it's just because
to me that's just calories
that i don't like gummy bears
it's just like it's a bunch of calories
and it's not something i enjoy if i'm
gonna get candy go to the movie i want
some [ __ ] you know chocolate covered
almonds or some [ __ ] snow caps or
something like that i want something
like that
um yes i don't waste calories on
something i don't really like
so
most of the time i'm safe because
honestly
i don't if i go to the store i don't buy
candy
um
almost never like i said if i'm gonna
buy something like that's a treat i'll
buy like a you know a coffee drink or
something but
i don't buy a lot of candy as a treat
for myself she's talking bad about me
this is my proof i'm not talking bad
about you yeah i don't eat it all at
once i eat a little bit nobody said that
little by little
okay
with my lemon heads
but these these are
these are my dollar [ __ ]
gummy bears
they're good they're just like any other
gummy bear
but like i said you can buy those all
day long because i
i don't like them
i don't honestly i don't like a lot of
fruity candy i don't like a lot of
the only fruity candy i like is maybe
starburst but honestly if
if i'm paying for candy and i'm like
okay well i'm gonna use up my daily
stipulation of
you know treat
calories on this candy yeah i'm not
gonna buy like a freezer well mary they
got the sour worms up there too for a
dollar big old pack um
they had them all tila says tom is doing
a candy mukbang and i'm here for it
i gotta steal off of that [ __ ] how long
we've been on the show um three hours
and fifty it's almost time to oh man
it's a four-hour show it's time to come
off bridgette says i love snow caps when
i was younger honestly you know what
okay i don't know if um
[Music]
maybe
i am high
i thought snow caps back in the old days
used to be bigger
like the size
the size of like a dime i thought
or maybe like a little bit maybe like a
nickel oh no yeah yeah that's how big
they made them smaller right but
nowadays when you buy them because i
bought them a few times recently like
when we were going to the movies and
they're like and there's a chocolate
chip yeah yeah it's like a chocolate
chip size i'm like what the [ __ ] no they
made them smaller yeah i thought they
were like nickel sized yeah they were
bigger than that okay i thought it was
like mission okay good
i was resourcing them from a different
place because i was like looking in the
box going what the [ __ ] these are little
they're like chocolate chips with
[ __ ] these people little white
sprinkles on them these are about three
times that size that's what i thought
they did
and i kind of feel like even the picture
on the box
still mistakenly gives you the
impression you're big they're larger so
maybe that's kind of why i was still
thinking that because i remember always
being surprised when i opened the box
and they're like [ __ ] tiny well no
you still get a lot
and i still enjoy them so i don't think
it's a really good use to make their own
chocolate drops yeah they're buying
those chocolate drops now
gotta be
that's chocolate chips that they're
buying and then just cover them
save money yeah
tila says i usually get raisinets red
vines and a small popcorn
i'm not i don't love raisins i used to
like them when i was a kid but i'm not a
big fan of raisins
i do like chocolate covered nuts though
honestly
if i bought any snack at the movies
which i don't usually
i would usually get the bag of like
chocolate covered almonds publix makes
their own raisinets different
kinds of chocolate everything they're
big they're better than the raisinettes
just chocolate-covered raisins man
they're [ __ ] good they've got
chocolate-covered almonds over there
publix makes them
yes real good that's more my speed go in
there and you get a scoop and you put
them in the bag and you [ __ ] walk out
i don't think every publix has that
though
most of them do though i mean everyone
that i've been in had that
so
i don't i don't know even had dried
fruit where you can get a bunch of dried
like yeah yeah dried [ __ ] pineapple i
mean chocolate covered nuts um i'm
really into trail mix you can get trail
mixtures yeah trail mix i like that i
like um what was i gonna say there was a
thing that's like uh
[ __ ] i thought it was
i forgot what i was going to say i
forgot what i was going to say oh well
yeah it's late we've been on here for
almost four hours it's not late it's
only a quarter past eight we've been on
for four hours though
no it's three hours and 18 minutes 18
minutes that's
substantially less than four two and a
half hours is the is the perfect size
for a show if you ask me
cheryl says i don't know what red vines
are they're licorice yeah it's red
licorice but
not like twizzlers they're thinner yeah
they're thinner and they're straight
there's actually um in the candy world
there's a big rivalry between
red twizzlers and red vines
with some people you know people coming
down on even honestly i don't like
either one so
i don't have a dog in that fight i'm
just saying i like black earth licorice
especially scandinavian black licorice
it's a lot better kind of salty what's
that
what's the matter pookie
she's making some kind of like follow me
what's the matter
what's your name
she's been talking all day
i don't know what the hell is the matter
with her
she's just kind of dead
yeah she's like hey hey hey
she you know what i mean uh i washed up
you know i cleaned the bathroom and [ __ ]
yesterday and so i you know cleaned that
area and i straightened up all my makeup
in my dressing room
pookie loves my hair brush
and
whenever i brush my hair
she gets like super upset because she
she'll jump up on my chest and she'll be
like why are you not brushing pookie
with this brush right now like don't
brush your hair brush me she likes to
rub against the brush
so i cleaned the area where the hair
brush was and i put the hairbrush in a
different place
and she seems a little
out of sorts about it she kept jumping
up on there and like looking for the
brush
and then she kind of found it she's like
wait is this the brush no
and then like she kept jumping up there
and be like
she kept like making noises like that
where's the brush
she's very mad that i moved the brush
i didn't move it far but you know
i seriously can't brush my hair anymore
because
she she splayed out
she's got like her little and then her
back feet are like way behind her like
that like she's in launch mode
and she's got a little bit like belly
sticking out on the side she's like so
funny
um
chocolate covered marshmallows
i'm not a marshmallow fan but you know
i know some people like them but i don't
i don't really like marshmallows
jenny do a thinner review i honestly i
wanted to because they put that on hulu
not too long ago
jenny what uh do you are you interested
in selling any uh your uh motorcycle
gear
why'd you ask me that because melissa's
looking for that kind of stuff oh yeah
she could have it i guess yeah well i'll
send her a picture i get a helmet and a
jacket yeah
she's actually looking for black but i
said i don't know it's pink black and
white what you have and you've really
never used it
yeah i just used it once or twice yeah
where is it it's in it's it's in the
closet i mean it's around here somewhere
it's right here i don't remember where
it
is uh do y'all have a brush for pookie
though my boy's like yeah um i do i have
like some of those brush gloves
and
to be honest i know this is weird but a
lot of times i just brush her with my
hairbrush and then i pull all her hair
out just brush my hair with it i don't
care
she likes my brush i don't know
for whatever reason but the weird thing
is like i try to brush her with it and
she gets like real she just wants to jam
her face
into the brush so she just
she just wants me to hold it there so
she can go
and push her face into it
the same as we were talking about like
earlier with her meat sticks you can't
just put the meat stick on the floor and
have her eat it you have to hold it
in your hand
and hold it out for her like that and
then she'll eat it if you put on the
floor she won't eat it she'll just leave
it there
it has to be like a whole
situation you know what i'm saying
uh let's see
tila says cats are the best they are i
mean you know
she's a brat but
you know
all right let's go ahead and wrap it up
jim
okay we're gonna wrap it up the show has
been going on for a long time we're
running out of things to talk about
show's starting to get boring
okay
[Laughter]
so uh go ahead all right so uh have a
good friday wrestle friday night you
guys wherever the hell you are
we will be back on sunday probably
talking about the
uh world premiere the movie that we saw
okay
yeah okay
all right so uh thanks everybody for
driving by we will see you guys on
sunday afternoon